GOOD AFTERNOON WE'RE GOING TO
CALL TO ORDER THIS MEETING OF
THE UTILITY AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE- WE'RE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON- TO ADDRESS A NUMBER
OF ITEMS THAT ARE IMPORTANT. TO
THIS- COMMITTEE INTO THE STATE.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE AGENDA
LET ME JUST ASK THE SERGEANTS
IF THEY COULD TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BEFORE WE MOVE
ON TO THE AGENDA I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
MAKE- FIRST IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY. WE WILL HOLD OUR ANNUAL
REVIEW OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
OVERSIGHT HEARING. SECOND AS
ALWAYS I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARINGS AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE CHAMBER OR REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. FINALLY WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SCENE AND WEARING
MASKS AT ALL TIMES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE'RE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE IN PERSON. WE HAVE A
FEW OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. IN TODAY'S
CHAMBER. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND. AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. WE WILL ALSO BE
USING MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGHOUT. WHICH MAY
WHICH WHICH ANYBODY THIS MAY
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY UTILITIES AND
ENERGY WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
THE TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOUR MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE AND
WILL NEED TO MOVE YOURSELF.
UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED ON TO
SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS. WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO EIGHT
THREE AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO HELP. WE'RE ALSO
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. MOVING ON TO THE
AGENDA WE HAVE FOR MEASURES ON
THE AGENDA TODAY. A TO OUR ON
CONSENT AND THOSE CONSENT ITEMS
ARE ITEM THREE SB FOUR SEVEN
NINE LAYERED. ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SB SEVEN FIVE SIX HUESO. AS WE
PROCEED WITH THE WITNESSES AND
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO
ENSURE WE MAINTAIN ORDER AND
RUN AN EFFICIENT AND FAIR
HEARING. TESTIMONY IS LIMITED
TO FOUR MINUTES TOTAL FOR EACH
SIDE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ON A MEASURE PLEASE
BRIEFLY STATE YOUR NAME
POSITION AND AFFILIATION IF ANY.
I ALSO ASK THAT MEMBERS SPEAK
DIRECTLY INTO YOUR MICROPHONE
VOTES. THE NOW CALLED. CALL THE
ROLL FOR QUORUM SO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. STOCKTON HOLDEN HERE
PATTERSON. BARRICADE HAND
BETTER K. HAND HERE. MARIA CHEN
CHEN HERE CUNNINGHAM CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA HERE
EDUARDO GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA
HERE MAYES MURATSUCHI RCG HERE
CORK. WORK HERE REYES REYES
HERE SANTIAGO KING. THAT'S A
QUORUM IS PRESENT- LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO CONSENT TO I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THERE'S
BEEN A MOTIONS AND- MARKET HAS.
DOCTOR QUIRK SECOND. SECRETARY
TO CALL THE ROLL ON THE CAN
FILE. SB FOUR SEVEN NINE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS. SB SEVEN FIVE
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I PATTERSON
THERE CAN PARA QUE HAN I BURKE.
RIO CHEN CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I'D CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA I AM
MAYES. MURATSUCHI RCG I'D WORK.
QUIRK I REYES. REYES ICE
SANTIAGO. TAKING THAT'S NINE
NINE NICE THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO MOVE OUT OF COMMITTEE
BUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OPEN ABSENT MEMBERS WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM ONE S. B.
EIGHTEEN SKINNER- THIS IS
HYDROGEN GREEN HYDROGEN
EMISSIONS OF GREENHOUSE GASES
AS ALWAYS WELCOME SENATOR
SKINNER WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING YOUR PRESENTATION IT
DOES ENJOY DO PASSES A MINUTE
TO NATURAL RESOURCES YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANKS SO MUCH TO YOUR
HOME. IS A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILLS ARE SECOND. HAS BEEN
SECONDED. SENATOR PLEASE
PROCEED. ARM WELL IF THERE MAY
BE. BUT ALSO THIS THE AND
MICHAEL OFF JUST VERY THREE-
THE BILL JUST ALLOWS US TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF. GREEN HYDROGEN
STILL TO BE FULLY DEFINED NOT
DEFINED IN THE BILL BUT-
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE GREAT
AGENCIES AND GREAT MINDS THAT
WILL HELP US DO SO. BUT IT
ALLOWS US TO INCORPORATE
SOMETHING THAT CAN HELP US BOTH
DECARBONISE REDUCE POLLUTION.
IN VERY EFFECTIVE WAYS IN A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT MODES
WHETHER IT'S ELECTRICITY
STORAGE OR FEELING
TRANSPORTATION HEAVY DUTY FOR
EXAMPLE AND SUCH THINGS. AND
SO- WITH THAT'LL JUST TURNED TO
MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
THEN- IF ANYONE HAS QUESTIONS
HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM SO WE'LL
START WITH JANICE LYNN WHO'S AT
THE GREEN HYDROGEN COALITION
FOLLOWED BY ANDREW. MEREDITH OF
THE BUILDING. OKAY SO WE WILL
TO A JENNIFER PLAN FOR. WITH A
HIGH COALITION. HERE CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK. HELLO YES YOU CAN
BE. OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER THANK YOU CHAIR
HOLDEN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME'S JANET FLANNER AND THE
PHONE AND PRESIDENT THE GREEN
HYDROGEN COALITION FOR A NEW
FIVE A ONCE THREE NON. WHOSE
MISSION IS TO ADVANCE HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION AND USE APPS GAIL TO
ACCELERATE MULTI SECTORAL
DECARBONISATION- I'M GONNA KEEP
MY COMMENTS VERY BRIEF TODAY
BUT JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW WE
REALIZED THAT DEFINING GREEN
HAS IMPORTANT WERE WORKING WITH.
TO IT TO COME TO TERMS A PROPER
AGING GUIDE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE FOR SENATE BILLY
AS THE SAN TRISTAN AN VISION
AND LEGAL AND FRAMEWORK FOR
CALIFORNIA TO REALIZE THE
BENEFITS OF GREEN HIGH TEACHER-
THERE'S I WANT TO COVER TODAY
WHY IT'S A GREAT WAY TO ALLOW.
INDY CAR OUR SUPPLY WE CAN OUR
FUN RENEWABLE RE. INTO A FLEX
ZERO CARD FUEL THANK DISPLACING
ANY OTHER FOSSILS LAP.
INCREASING ENERGY REALIZED AND
RESILIENCE SECONDLY WITH GREEN
WE CAN READ VALUABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR AFFORDABLE
ENERGY TRANSIT. AS AN EXAM AND
W. IS AN THE PROCESS OF CAN IT
TO REMAINING COAL. LOCATED IN
CENTRAL NEW TO A HUNDRED PER
GREEN HYDROGEN COMBINES GAS TO.
AND LYFT GREEN HIDE IS THE
TREMENDOUS ACTION DEVELOP AND
JOB CREATING EXPORT OUT FOR K.
MANY COUNTRIES THE WORLD ARE
BUYING TO BECOME LEADING HIGH
COULD. INCLUDING AUSTRIA CHILE
SPAIN AND ARABIA CAL SHOULD BE
ONE OF THEM WITHOUT B. E. K. IS
AT RISK OF FALLING GLOBALLY I
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR AYE THOSE
ONCE BILL EIGHTEEN TO A CAL CAN
GLOBAL LEADER. IN THE CLEAN
ENERGY TRANSITION THANK YOU.
THANK OF CENTER BE WE MOVE ON
TO YOUR NEXT. THERE WERE A THE
WERE YES OF. THANK YOU- CHAIR
APOLOGY THAT. I ALL OF THE
MINUTES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR SAID. A WITNESS AND REMAIN
WITH THE BUILDING AND CAN TRADE.
STIR MERIT YOU CAN PERCEIVE
YOUR TESTIMONY. GET OFF MR CHIU
MEMBERS OF THE- ON THE OF THE
NO MEMBERS OF THE CAL STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL I'M HERE TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT SB EIGHTEEN.
I FIRST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
FACT THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY HERE
IN PERSON TODAY WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE ALL DONE
OVER THE LAST YEAR IN LIGHT OF
COBIT. WITH THAT BEING SAID THE
REASON THAT WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL OF GREEN HYDROGEN
IS THIS IS TRULY AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TRANSITION OURSELVES JUST
LEAD TOWARDS A CLEAN AND
RENEWABLE RESOURCE. AS YOU ALL
KNOW IN THIS BUILDING THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES HAVE BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THE LAST TWO DECADES. WE HAVE
BUILT OVER TO OVER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF SOLAR
ALONE THE EQUIVALENT OF TWELVE
NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS. WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE GREEN HYDROGEN
OFFERS ANOTHER FRONT HERE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MEET ITS
AMBITIOUS. CLIMATE GOALS. SIMP
PUT WE CANNOT IGNORE WE CAN'T
IGNORE TECHNOLOGY LIKE THIS IF
WE'RE GOING TO GET TO CARBON
NEUTRALITY IN CALIFORNIA. ALL
AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGIES HAVE TO
BE EXPLORED. THEY HAVE TO BE
DEVELOPED. AND I WAS THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER SAID
CALIFORNIA HAS A HISTORY OF
DOING THAT WITH EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE GOOD
PAYING JOBS IN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL. AGAIN THAT COULD HELP US AWAY FROM THE GOOD
PAYING JOBS IN THE OIL AND
NATURAL GAS SECTOR THAT ALREADY
EXIST. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF AGAIN A HALF
MILLION MEMBERS SEVENTY
THOUSAND OF WHICH ARE PRINT
THIS IS. 70% OF WHOM ARE PEOPLE
OF COLOR WE ASK FOR YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WE DO
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE IN
PERSON AS WELL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WHO WILL BE
PRESENTED AND OPPOSITION
TESTIFIED BY PHONE. THAT IS
JOHN SCHAEFER WITH HUMBLE THREE
FIFTY .ORG. FOR MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN ENSURE THE JOHN
SCHAEFER IS ON THE LINE WE WILL
RECEIVE HIS TESTIMONY NOW. I
THINK I'M ON THE LINE. THEN WE
HEAR YOU AND YOU CAN PROCEED.
THANK YOU CHAIR HOLDEN SENATOR
SKINNER AND OTHER MEMBERS.
THREE FIFTY DOT ORG BELIEVES
SAID HYDROGEN HAS GREAT
POTENTIAL TO STORE ENERGY AND
GET US OFF FOSSIL FUELS
INTERESTED CLIMATE CRISIS BUT
WE OPPOSE S. B. EIGHTEEN
BECAUSE IN ITS PRESENT FORM IT
DOESN'T DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
GREEN ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN AND
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN. IN A
SEMANTIC SHELL GAME S. B.
EIGHTEEN COULD ALLOW DIRTY
ELECTRICITY TO BE USED TO MAKE
SO CALLED CLEAN HYDROGEN. TO
AVOID GREENWASHING ALL
REFERENCES IN S. B. EIGHTEEN
SHOULD SAY GREEN ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN. THERE'S ANOTHER
PROBLEM TOO SB EIGHTEEN
MODIFIES P. U. C. CODE SECTION
FOUR HUNDRED POINT THREE WHICH
IN TURN REFERENCES SECTION FOUR
HUNDRED POINT TWO. NEW LANGUAGE
SHOULD BE ADDED TO SECTION FOUR
HUNDRED POINT TWO NAMELY THE
PHRASE USING ELECTRICITY FROM
WIND OR SOLAR SOURCES. THUS
SECTION FOUR HUNDRED POINT TWO
SHOULD READ FOR PURPOSES OF
THIS ARTICLE GREEN ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN MEANS HYDROGEN GAS
PRODUCED THROUGH ELECTROLYSIS
USING ELECTRICITY FROM WIND OR
SOLAR SOURCES- AND DOES NOT
INCLUDE. IN THE REST OF THE
SECTION IS OKAY FOR OUR
GRANDCHILDREN SAY CAN TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA ON TRACK TO ADDRESS
THE CLIMATE CRISIS WE HOPE
YOU'LL REJECT SB EIGHTEEN NOW
AND THEN CONSIDER LEGISLATION
THAT CORRECTS THESE
SHORTCOMINGS. SO WHO AM I JOHN
SHAPER RETIRED ENGINEER FORTY
YEARS EXPERIENCE IN ENERGY AND
A PHD FROM STANFORD THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS- STEVEN
ROSENBLOOM WITH THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. YEAH MY
NAME IS A DOCTOR STEVEN
ROSENBLUM- THANK YOU FOR.
HOLDING FOR THE- TO SPEAK. OF
THE PHD IN PRODUCED BERKELEY
AND I'M HERE PAY REPRESENT
THREE FIFTY SO VALLEY. AND NOT
I TRIED ESSENTIALLY SO- THE
BASIC DIRECTION THAT JOHN TO
PRESENT- OR THIS BILL THIS BILL
HAS A VERY LARGE GOAL TO ME DID.
OF GREEN HIDE INTO. HOWEVER IN
IN THE LARGEST THAT IN THE DEEP.
THE MAIN PROBLEM IS WHICH IS
BELIEVED TO OUR INTO. DETECTORS
DEFINITION OF THE TERM GREEN
HYBRID. WHICH APPEAR EIGHTEEN
IN THE WITH BILL. SO I WOULD
LIKE TO PROPOSE THAT EVERYWHERE
IN THE BILL THAT TO TURN GREEN
HYDROGEN PEERS BETTER BE
REPLACED BYTURN GREEN ALECTRA
LATER CARTER CAME. AND THAT THE
DEFINITION OF PEAS AND PETER
SEE FOUR HUNDRED POINT TO BE
MODIFIED AS FOLLOWS QUOTE. FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THIS ARTICLE
GREEN ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN
NEED HYDROGEN GAS PRODUCED
THROUGH A PROCESS OF WATER.
USING ELECTRICITY FROM WIND
SOLAR HYDRO OR GEOTHERMAL
SOURCES AND DOES NOT INCLUDE
HYDROGEN GAS THEN STARTED USING
CARBON CONTAINING. FEEDSTOCKS
IN COURT. THESE CHANGE WILL
HELP ENSURE THE HYDROGEN GAS
PRODUCED. WILL NOT ANY- OR
MIDDLE AMOUNTS OF CARBON AND
WILL HELP CALIFORNIANS MEETING
IT'S TWENTY THIRTY AND TWENTY
FIFTY CARBON EMISSIONS
REDUCTION GOALS. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
SPEAK TO THIS AND I HOPE THAT.
WE WILL GET OUT OF THE BILL SB
EIGHTEEN THAT ACHIEVES ITS
DESIRED GOALS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT- DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES- NONE THAT I CAN SEE
BUT IF WE OKAY ON THE VERY TOP
OF WITNESSES IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER OF THE FLOOR OR THE
GALLERY WE HAVE SOMEONE IN THE
GALLERY. IN OPPOSITION OR IN
BETWEEN THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON S. B. EIGHTEEN.
COULD HAVE SO STATE YOUR NAME.
DIGITIZATION ON YOUR POSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROWN
ON BEHALF OF THE UTILITY
WORKERS UNION OF AMERICA IN
SUPPORT I THINK I MAY HAVE
MISSED THE- SUPPORT QUEUE
EARLIER THEY GIVE. YOU'RE GOOD.
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE PHONE LINES- THEY'RE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
S. B. EIGHTEEN PHONE MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OR SHARE THEIR
CONCERNS ON SB EIGHTEEN. THANK
YOU TO STATE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHTEEN ME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. YEAH THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. SURE AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE FIVE IN. WE HAVE
TEN IN Q. WILL GO FIRST THE
LINE FOURTEEN ONE FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON TIFFANY FAN ON BEHALF
OF AN E. THIRTEEN CUSTOMERS IN
CONTRA COSTA SOLANO NAPA IN
MARIN COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE. TWENTY TWO.
ON BEHALF OF THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS AND SUPPORT.
NEXUS LINE. TWENTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON STEVE WALKER YOUR
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF- THE
SENATOR TRANSPORTATION
DEPARTMENTS ALAMEDA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT COURT THAT EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE. THIRTY
THREE ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON
DILLON JAFFA BEHALF CAL START
IN SUPPORT AT THE EIGHTEEN.
LINE TWENTY TWO ZERO. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK WITH THE
CONCERNED POSITION I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE OFFICE
OFFICE. NINE TWENTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON- SHAREHOLDING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TIM
CARMICHAEL WITH SEMPRA ENERGY
UTILITY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
EIGHTEEN NINE THIRTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS CAN BE
ON BEHALF OF U. A. W. WESTERN
STATES IN SUPPORT OF SB.
EIGHTEEN WHAT ON NINE TWENTY
SIX. HELLO THIS IS RYAN MCCARTY
ON BEHALF OF AQUA HI GREX AND
MAGNUM DEVELOPMENT BOTH IN
SUPPORT. YOU HAVE LYING.
EIGHTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON JULIA
LEVIN WITH THE BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOALS OF
SB EIGHTEEN BUT WE ARE IN A
SUPPORT REPRESENTATIVE SESSION
WE SUPPORT THE CHANGE TO REMOVE
THE PROVISIONS THAT ARE LIMITED
TO ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN
HYDROGEN FROM ORGANIC WASTE CAN
BE EVEN LOWER CARBON AND
PROVIDE MANY ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS SO WE THINK ADOPTING
THE DEFINITIONS IS IMPORTANT
BEFORE LIMITING PROGRAMS TO
SPECIFIC TECHNOLOGIES. WE ALSO
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE
THAT ANY HYDROGEN POLICIES
FOCUS ON IN STATE- DELIVERED
HYDROGEN AND NOT SUBSIDIZED
PAPER ONLY TRANSACTIONS. GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT THIS TIME
THEY'RE NOT FOR THE LINE TO
KEEP. THANK YOU- THAN EXHAUSTS
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM
AT THIS MOMENT SO WE'LL TURN
TO. OTHER COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT NO TO THAT ON THE
AMENDMENTS WHEN THE COMMENTS
WERE MADE AROUND- GREEN
HYDROGEN THAT THE AMENDMENT
STRIKE ALL PROVISIONS MANDATING
GREEN. ELECTRO WHAT POLITIC
HYDROGEN BE CONSIDERED IN PEACE
THE ACTIONS. XCERRA SO- MISS OF
THE CENTER SKINNER IF YOU WANT
TO ELABORATE ON SOME OF THE
RESPOND IN MORE DETAIL TO SOME
OF WHAT YOU HEARD- FEEL FREE
BUT WILL WILL TURN TO MEMBERS
NOW DOCTOR QUIRK- AND MISTER
MURATSUCHI YES THANK YOU. UP
FOR THE OPPOSITION I THINK THAT
THEIR DEFINITION OF GREEN
HYDROGEN IS TOO LIMITED. FOR
ONE IT WAS JUST SOLAR AND WIND
FOR THE OTHER WITH SOLAR WIND.
GEOTHERMAL AND HYDRO I DO THINK
BIOENERGY SHOULD BE CONSIDERED.
ARMED I DON'T THINK ANYONE IN
THEIR RIGHT MIND IS GOING TO
CONSIDER DIRTY FOSSIL FUEL
MAKING HYDROGEN GREEN HYDROGEN
AYE. I DON'T EVEN THINK WE HAVE
TO MENTION THAT- THE AUTHOR
WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT SHE HAS
A GOOD. VIABLE DEFINITION
EITHER AL OR LEAVING IT UP TO-
THE- AGENCY. SO I VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I'D LIKE
TO ASK TO BE CO AUTHOR. CERTAIN
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. THAT COULD
OCCUR. MR MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I ALSO. I WOULD LIKE
TO JOIN THE BANDWAGON TO BE
ASKED TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR- I REMEMBER WHEN TOYOTA
WAS STILL IN MY DISTRICT THAT-
IF THEY WERE VERY EXCITED TO
DEMONSTRATE THEIR- HYDROGEN
MIRAI AND- THEY WERE SO EXCITED
THAT YOU KNOW THE EXHAUST THE
ONLY THING THAT WOULD BE COMING
OUT AS WATER. AND- COURSE I WAS
ALL EXCITED TO BECAUSE IT.
SEEMS TO BE SUCH A PROMISING
TECHNOLOGY AND STARTED.
LEARNING MORE ABOUT ALL THE- AS
THE HOUSES POINTS OUT THE
HYDROGEN COLOR WHEEL YOU KNOW
THE WHOLE ANALYSIS AS TO HOW.
CLEAN OR HOW DURING THE PROCESS
IS IN TERMS OF THE PRODUCTION.
OF THE HYDROGEN FUEL. I WANTED
TO THE SATURDAY KNOW THAT THE
THAT THE CHILDREN NINE I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU KNOW THIS BUT THE
WE HAD THE- LEAD TO A
DELEGATION OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
TO JAPAN. WHILE ON A TRIP
SPONSORED BY THE GOVERNMENT OF
JAPAN WHERE WE TOWARD IN IN
PARTICULAR THERE WAS A- WE WANT
TO FOCUS IN A- WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY NOW IS. YOU KNOW
SO MUCH OF IT IS BECOMING A
NUCLEAR WASTELAND BUT- THEY'RE
CERTAINLY TRYING TO CREATE THAT
AS AN OPPORTUNITY WHERE THEY
THEY- DEMONSTRATED THIS THEY
THEY HAVE THIS HYDROGEN.
DEMONSTRATION PLANNED WITH A
USE ALL SOLAR. TO PRODUCE-
GREEN ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN-
AND THEY WORK SHOWCASING HOW
THEY WANTED TO USE A NOT ONLY
AN- TRANSPORTATION NOT ONLY
FOR. CARS BUT ALSO THE HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS I AS AS THE YOU
KNOW THE TO TWO FEET AND POWER
HOMES- AND SO WITH THE- YOU
KNOW IT'S REALLY EXCITING THAT-
THAT CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW IS-
HOPEFULLY NOT GOING TO. BE LEFT
BEHIND BUT- IS GOING TO BE PART
OF THIS THIS IS A VERY.
EXCITING GOOD A TECHNOLOGY THAT
HAS THE SUPPORT OF OUR FRIENDS
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES AS
WELL AS- ARE YOU ARE ARE
UTILITIES. AND ENERGY PRODUCERS
AND SO. ON I WANT TO ASK YOU
THOUGH. IF YOU'RE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOUR
ORIGINAL BILL WAS PROPOSING A
DIFFERENT TO LIMIT THE USE OF A-
HYDROGEN- TO BE CONSIDERED IN
THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROCESS
THE I. R. P. AND FUTURE ENERGY
STORAGE PROCUREMENT GOES SAID
BASED ON YOUR- EXPERIENCE AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT GREEN
HYDROLYTIC AND HYDROGEN IS IN
FACT. THE ONLY ASSURED- GREEN
RENEWABLE- HYDROGEN FUEL.
THROUGH THEIR THIS ARM THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THE
QUESTION SO AND I WILL TRY TO
BE BRIEF- OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA
STARTED TO MAKE A COMMITMENT TO
HYDROGEN BACK IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS BUT AT THAT POINT WE
THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE PRODUCTION
PROCESS WERE PRIMARILY USING
FOSSIL FUELS AND IN FACT THE
CARBON PROFILE PARTRIDGE IN AT
THAT TIME WAS NOT SOMETHING I
THINK THOSE OF US WHO REALLY
WANT TO DECARBONISE WOULD BE
WOULD HAVE ADVOCATE. BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW TECHNOLOGIES
IMPROVE A LOT TO RESEARCH
INVESTMENTS AND WE NOW KNOW WE
NOT ONLY DO WE KNOW THERE IS A
PART OF IT WAS COST IT IS
BECOMING MORE COST EFFECTIVE TO
PRODUCE HYDROGEN THROUGH OTHER
MEANS ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE WE HAVE- MADE SUCH HUGE
INVESTMENTS IN SOLAR AND WIND
AND OTHER RENEWABLE SOURCES. AT
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE AT TIMES
OVER PRODUCTION SO THAT WE CAN
AFFORD TO USE THAT TO PRODUCE
HYDROGEN NOW IS POINTED OUT BY
OUR COLLEAGUE DR CORK THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS TO PRODUCE NON BROWN
OR NON CARBON HYDROGEN AND SO
JUST STEPPING BACK IN TWENTY
NINETEEN I CARRIED BILL AND WE
GAVE A DEFINITION TO GREEN
ELECTRIC HYBRID ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN THAT DEFINITION STANCE
WE HAVE A STATUTORY DEFINITION
FOR GREEN ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN. NOW IF WE DO NOT OR
IF WE FOR PURPOSES OF SAY THIS
BILL ARE UNABLE TO LAND ON A
BROADER DEFINITION THEN IN
EFFECT THE STATUTORY DEFINITION
THAT EXISTS IS THE ONE THE
GREEN ELECTROLYTIC SO FOR THOSE
WHO ARE REALLY CONCERNED THAT
WE MAY GO IN A DIRECTION THAT
WOULD BE NOT GREAT FOR CARBON
THEY DO NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THAT AT THIS MOMENT YEAH. WE
UNDERTOOK AN EFFORT TO COME UP
WITH. THE DEFINITION INVOLVING
A LOT OF STICKLE- SO WE JUST
HAVE ONLY YET YOU KNOW THINGS
ARE TRICKY. SO WE'LL KEEP
TALKING. AND WE'LL DO OUR BEST-
BUT FOR THE MOMENT I THINK WE
ARE QUITE SAFE THOSE OF US WHO
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE CARBON
SIDE OF IT. TO STILL PROCEED
BUT THIS ADDITIONALLY DOES NOT
LIMIT OUR AGENCIES FROM
PLANNING NOTICE THAT THIS IS
PLANNING. FROM PLANNING ON HOW
TO UTILIZE. THE HYDROGEN ON A
BROADER WAY SHOULD WE BE AT A
PLACE WHERE WE EITHER COME WITH
A GREAT DEFINITION OR LAND ON A
WAY TO. TO ACT- PRODUCE EXTRACT
WHATEVER HYDROGEN IN ADDITIONAL
WAYS THAT ARE LOW TO NO CARB SO
THAT'S WHY I AM COMFORTABLE
WITH HOW WE ARE PROCEEDING.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- MISS
CARRILLO AND THEN MISTER GARCIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL I TOO
WOULD LIKE TO WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT B. AFFORDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN ENOUGH
COAUTHORS WHILE STRONGLY
BELIEVE IN AND WHAT YOUR INTENT
IS I AM A VERY CLEAR I AM
SLIGHTLY DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
AMENDMENTS TO TAKE OUT THE P.
U. C. I. A. I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
A YEAR TWO YEARS FROM NOW ABOUT
THE NEED FOR THE P. YOU SEE. TO
ADDED HYDROGEN AS PART OF A
STRATEGIC PLAN WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY OUT TO BE
THINKING ABOUT ON THEIR OWN AND
THE HEARING THERE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A LATER I THINK IT
WOULD BE A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT THEIR STRATEGIC PLAN
OVERALL IS TO ACHIEVE.
OBVIOUSLY LOWERING OUR ARE. A
REDUCTION OF FOSSIL FUELS WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME. WORKING ON
THE VERY REAL NEED TO. UPDATE
THE GRID CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES THINK ABOUT
RENEWABLE ENERGIES FROM OUR
DIVERSE PORTFOLIO. PERSPECTIVE
SO WHILE I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
BILL IS MOVING FORWARD AND
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT. I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON HOW WE ACTUALLY ACHIEVE.
THE LARGER SCOPE FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE AND FOR AREAS LIKE MINE
AND OTHERS THAT. A WHILE I
REPRESENT A VERY. URBAN DANCE
COMMUNITY. UP WE STILL GET
NOTICES FROM LADWP DURING
SEARCHES. NOT TO PLUG IN.
VEHICLES BECAUSE THE GREAT
CAN'T HANDLE IT. AND SO WHILE
WE- AIM TO ACHIEVE. ARE THESE
INCREDIBLE GOALS WE NEED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO GET THERE.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT THANK YOU.
RESEARCH YEAH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
WILL BE SUPPORTING AND I DID
JUST WANT TO POSE. THE
QUESTION- FOR THE PUBLIC FOR
STAKEHOLDERS IN MY DISTRICT- WE
HAVE ALTERNATIVE FUEL
DEVELOPMENT FUNDED BY THE
ENERGY COMMISSION. AND THERE'S
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN- APPROVING
TECHNOLOGIES SUCH AS THE-
D'AMICO ETHER- RENEWABLE TIME
OF EITHER- TO MEET OUR
WORLDWIDE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
ON CLIMATE AND ACHIEVING. A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT STEPS TO BE
ABLE TO. DEMONSTRATE AND AROUND
THE WORLD VOLVO TRUCKS MACK
TRUCKS AND OTHER. TYPES OF-
COMPANIES HAVE UTILIZED THIS-
FUEL RENEWABLE FUEL. TO BE ABLE
TO DECARBONISE- THE FOOTPRINT
AND- THIS COMPANY IS LOCATED IN
MY DISTRICT AND- BRAWLEY
CALIFORNIA. THAT HAS- BROUGHT
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF- JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AND WE KNOW THAT
IT ALIGNS WITH- EXPENDABLES AN
OBJECT OF SOME OPEN THAT- THERE
WILL BE A SPACE- FOR THIS
CONVERSATION AS WELL IN THE
BILL. AS IT MOVES FORWARD AND I
KNOW YOU'VE COMMITTED TO DO
THAT BUT JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THAT THAT. KNOWN AS STATED. FOR
THE RECORD. GREAT THANK YOU.
GARCIA. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK IN THIS SPACE- I'M GONNA
BE VOTING FOR THE BILL TO THE I
DO THINK IT MERITS AS TO
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION ON THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING. AND I
THINK WE SHARE THE COMMON GOAL
THAT AS WE'RE DOING THIS WORK
ENSURING THAT. THE BALLISTIC
PROFILE PICTURE OF CARBON YOU
KNOW AND IN THIS PROCESS IS
LIKE THAT WHICH WHEN I LOOK AT
THE OPPOSITION. WELL I DON'T
KNOW THEIR AMENDMENTS
THEMSELVES ARE ACCURATE I DO
THINK THE CONCERNS OR ISSUES
THAT WE SHARE AND WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE GET RIGHT AND SO. I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD AND AFT
MOMENTS BEFORE TO HAVE INPUT
ALONG THE WAY IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE WHERE IT'S EITHER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'LL SAY NO OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE- I WAS I
JOIN WITH THE MEMBERS AND
CONTINUE INTO- KNOWLEDGE YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND- NOT JUST THE
SPACE BUT RECOGNIZING THE NEED
TO EXPLORE A VARIETY OF
RENEWABLE OPTIONS THAT GET US
TO OUR GOAL BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE AND CERTAINLY WITH THAT
BEING THE DRIVER AND THIS BEING
A PLANNING BILL IT CERTAINLY
GIVES US THE FOUNDATION TO
BUILD ON YOUR PREVIOUS WORK BUT
ALSO ALLOWS US TO. CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT HOW TO BE MORE GRANULAR
AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO THE NEXT
EFFORTS AND SO- WELL LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO JOIN YOUR BILL AS A CO
AUTHOR I DON'T DO THAT VERY
OFTEN BUT I THINK THIS IS
CERTAINLY ONE THAT IS- A VERY
APPROPRIATE AND NECESSARY AS WE
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE OPTIONS.
AND SO WITH THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR AND WILL
LAST FOR. IT HERE IF YOU HAVE
ANY CLOSING. COMMENTS THEY WERE
HAPPY TO RECEIVE AT THIS
MOMENT. I DEFINITELY REMAIN
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT. WE
ARE NOT PURSUING A HYDROGEN
THAT WOULD. EXACERBATE OR
RATHER BE. CONTRARY TO OUR
DECARBONISATION GOALS SO YOU
HAVE THAT TOTAL COMMITMENT ON
MY PART AND- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU AMOUNTS SECRETARY CALLED
THE HOLDEN PRO THE ACTION ON
THE MOTION. SB EIGHTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
NATURAL RESOURCES HOLDEN HI
HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON. PARA QUE
HAN PARA QUE HAN I BURKE. BURKE
I CARILLO CARILLO AYE CHAN CHAN
ARE CUNNINGHAM. CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I MAYES
MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI RESEARCH
AYE CORK AYE WORK AREAS. REYES
ICE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I TíNH.
TWELVE IS. THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO MOVE OUT OF COMMITTEE
BUT WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN UP
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM TWO SB
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN WHY KASKI. A
LOCALLY PUBLICLY OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITIES INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANNING TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION MISTER WHAT
KOWSKI ON THE FLOOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- MEMBERS THIS
MEASURE WOULD REQUIRE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLAN
SUBMITTED BY PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES IS DEFINED BY THE
BILL IN THIS EXPLAINED IN THE
STAFF REPORT INCLUDE DETAILS ON
THE ELECTRIC. THE TRICITY RATE
DESIGN FOR THE TRANSPORTATION
RECOLLECT FOR CATION AS A STEP
TOWARD TALKS OUT OR EXPLAINS
RECRUITMENT CURRENTLY-
OBTAINING INFORMATION ON LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES BUT THEY DO NOT
INCLUDE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL. SIMPLY DOES A LOT OF
INTEREST IN THIS FLOOR IN THE
FLOOR IN THE SENATE ON THE
EMISSIONS FROM HEAVY MEDIUM-
DUTY VEHICLES EXPLICITLY
PROVIDING THAT ALL SECTORS OF
TRANSPORTATION WITH CATION-
INTO THE INTEGRATED WE- PLANS
ENSURES THAT WE COULD.
COMPREHENSIVE ELECTRICITY RATE
DESIGN AND THAT ALLOWS THE-
USERS OF POTENTIAL USERS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE COST
CONSIDERATIONS ARE GOING TO BE
PERFECT ZIP TECHNOLOGY FOR BOTH
VEHICLES AND FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH WITH THAT.
I RESPECT THE LAST FOR AND I
PUT. THERE'S A MOVE MOTION BY A
MEMBER GARCIA DR CORPUS SECOND.
OF WE'LL LOOK AT- WITNESSES AT
THIS POINT WE HAVE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND- SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. TO A TURN OF THE
MODERATOR FOR ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT AND BUT BEFORE WE DO
THAT WE NOTICE THERE'S NO ONE
IN THE CHAMBER THE BACK OF A-
CHAMBER WHERE THE GALLERY- TO
SPEAK. ON THIS BILL SO WE'LL
TURN TO PUBLIC COMMENT. AND ON
THE TELEPHONE LINES AND
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
THAT'S- PREPARED TO SPEAK AND
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT- OF OR
OPPOSITION. WE'RE JUST GENERAL
COMMENT ON SB FOUR THIRTY SEVEN
AND STATE JUST THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
ONE IN Q. IF ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE THE POSITION ON
AS BEFORE THIRTY SEVEN YEAR
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN THAT'S WHAT NEWMAN ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAINST THE WALL
COMING AFTER THE ALAMEDA CONTRA
COSTA TRANSIT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF SB PORT BIRDS UP
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q. NO THE
COP AND OTHER NO ONE ELSE ON
THE LINE. THAT'S CORRECT NO
UNDERLYING OKAY WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION- WE CERTAINLY DON'T
SUPPORT YOUR BILL THAT'S DUE
PASS- AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING IT MOVE ALONG IF YOU
HAVE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS. I
KNOW MISTER CHAIR OKAY I THINK
THEY WILL CALL VOTE. WILL CALL
THE ROLL ON- S. B. FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN. SB FOUR THIRTY SEVEN
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
AYE PATTERSON- QUE HAND BETTER
CAN I BURKE. BURKE AYE PEREA.
CHEN CHEN NOT VOTING CUNNINGHAM.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA I MAYES MAYES I
MURATSUCHI MASUCCI I WORK.
CLERK I. REYES. REYES ICE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE TANG.
SALIVA EYES SERRANO'S CAVE IN
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD WE'RE
GOING TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPENED
UP FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON
WHICH WE WILL DO IT THIS TIME
THAT- CONCLUDES OUR THANK YOU
SENATOR THAT CONCLUDES OUR BILL
PRESENTATIONS FOR TODAY WE WILL
NOW RE OPEN OUR ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. TO ADD ON SERGEANTS
PLEASE CALL THE ACTUAL NUMBERS
TO THE CHAMBER WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES ONLY
FIVE MINUTES AND THEN WE'LL
ADJOURN ARBIL HEARING AND TAKE
A FIVE MINUTE RECESS AND THEN
CALL TO ORDER OUR OVERSIGHT.
HEARING SO WILL HAVE A FIVE
MINUTE RECESS AND WILL ALLOW.
MEMBERS WHO NEED TO ADD ON.
YEAH. OKAY SO WE HAVE A FEW.
WHEN A STUDENT. MAN SECRETARY
LET'S MOVE TO THE TOP OF THE
PILE AND WE WILL. TAKE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THEN MOVED
DOWN TO THE OTHER ITEMS THAT WE
NEED MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO. SB
FOUR SEVEN NINE AND S. B. SEVEN
FIVE SIX. PATTERSON BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO. MAYES MAYES I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I CHIANG.
RICHARD THAT'S TWELVE CALENDAR
HIS CONSENT. PATTERSON I. YOUR
AVAILABLE. YEAH I HAVE YES I
HAVE YOU ON- ON THAT CONSENT
VOTE THAT WAS THIRTEEN ZERO.
STILL WAITING FOR TO MEMBERS.
WE WILL. CALL FIVE ONE. OKAY.
WE CAN GO AHEAD AND DO THAT NOW.
I'M SECRETARY WE CAN OPEN THE
ROLE ON ITEMS ONE AND TWO FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO. K. S. B.
EIGHTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
PATTERSON PATTERSON AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I CHIANG.
THAT'S. FOURTEEN ZERO. THE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB FOUR THREE SEVEN.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING. CARILLO
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING. TING.
ELEVEN ZERO. WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR AFTER MINUTES THAT
ON. AND FOR SB EIGHTEEN AND S.
B. FOR THIRTY SEVEN. CONSENT
ITEMS SB FOUR SEVEN NINE SB
SEVEN FIVE SIX. CARILLO TANG
CHIANG HI THAT'S FOURTEEN EYES
SERONO'S. SB EIGHTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES. TANG TANG I
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO. SB FOUR
THREE SEVEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS. CARILLO
TAKING. TANG I THAT'S. ELEVEN
ZERO. SO. VIRGINICA WE'RE JUST
WAITING FOR TRAIL ON THE
CONSENT ON EVERYTHING. I THANK.
FOR ME RIGHT DOWN. SO. ONE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. AND THE TO CONSENT
ITEMS.
FOUR SEVEN NINE SEVEN
FIVE SIX. OKAY. OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD AND CLOSE
THE ROLE ON S. B. EIGHTEEN AT
GETS OUT. FIFTEEN TO ZERO. SB
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. ELEVEN TWO
ZERO. AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR
INCLUDING SB FOUR SEVENTY NINE
AND SB. SEVEN FIFTY SIX
FOURTEEN ZERO. SO HAVING CAN
COLLUDED OUR BUSINESS AS A
COMMITTEE ON THE BILLS THIS
AFTERNOON. THE HEARING ON OUR
BILLS. IS INCLUDED. WE WILL NOW
START OUR ANNUAL REVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE. I'D LIKE TO
CALL THE ORDER COURT CALL TO
ORDER THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
YOU TO IN INTERVIEWS FOR THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARNG. WE'RE HERE
TO DISCUSS THE ANNUAL REVIEW OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE. TO START WE
HAVE SOME HOUSEKEEPING TO GO
OVER. WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE ANYWHERE IN
MASSIVE. AT ALL TIMES HERE IN
THE CHAMBER THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING AS WE
MENTIONED. EARLIER THIS
AFTERNOON AND WE ARE. WE HAVE
VERY LIMITED SPACE SO PALACE
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
WE ALSO HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI PARTICIPATING. I
BELIEVE HE IS GOING TO BE HERE
HE IS GOING TO BE HERE. ARE WE
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING THE CALL
IN DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SEGMENT. OF THIS HEARING. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS AREA CODE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
UTILITIES AND ENERGY. COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON THE TV
SCREEN ADDITIONALLY I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING WHICH IS AS WE SAY
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE CHAMBER. OR
REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTION MUTED. NOW
THESE ARE CERTAINLY DYNAMIC
TIMES IN THE ENERGY SECTOR.
CALIFORNIA IS LEADING THE
CHARGE IN ITS RENEWABLE
INTEGRATION WHILE BALANCING THE
DEMANDS OF RELIABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY. TWENTY TWENTY
MARKED A RECORD SETTING YEAR OF
WILDFIRES AND OUR STATE WHICH
WERE COMPOUNDED BY PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS. WE ALSO
HAD ROTATING OUTAGES SHUTTING
OFF OUR LIGHTS. AND GREATLY
IMPACTING THE HEALTH SAFETY AND
COMFORT OF CALIFORNIANS.
REFACED THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC INSURED PROTECTIONS
WERE IN PLACE FOR VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS SO THEIR WATER
ELECTRIC AND GAS SERVICES
REMAIN STABLE EVEN WHEN FACING
MANAGER MANY DIFFICULTIES
OUTSIDE THE HOME. THESE ISSUES
HIGHLIGHTED JUST A FRACTION OF
THE WORK FACED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. THE REGULATORY
ENTITY CHARGED WITH OVERSEEING
OUR VITAL SO THE UTILITY
SERVICES AND THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE. THE ENTITY
CHARGED WITH ENSURING RATEPAYER
INTERESTS ARE REPRESENTED AND
HER. TODAY WE INVITE THE
LEADERS OF THESE AGENCIES TO
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE UPDATE ON THE
WORK THAT HAS OCCUPIED THEIR
AGENCIES THE PAST YEAR. WITH
THAT LET ME WELCOME PRESIDENT
WHERE BILL BADGER. OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO PROVIDE HER
OPENING REMARKS. PRESIDENT
BOETTCHER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN AND GOOD AFTERNOON
SHAREHOLDER AND VICE CHAIR
PATTERSON AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY TO PROVIDE YOU WITH AN
OVERVIEW OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION'S
ACTIVITIES OVER THE PAST YEAR.
RIGHT FOR THE RECORD MY NAME IS
MERRY BELL BACHELOR AND I
SERVICE THE PRESIDENT OF THE C.
P. U. C. I'M JOINED BY MY
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY. TO
ASSIST ME IN ANSWERING ANY OF
YOUR QUESTIONS. RACHEL PETERSON
IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CPUC. AND EDWARD RANDOLPH
IS A DEPUTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR ENERGY CLIMATE AND POLICY
AND CAROLINE THOMAS JACOBS
DIRECTOR OF THE WILDFIRE SAFETY
DIVISION I JUST WANTED TO NOTE
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT WE ARE NOT
WEARING MASKS- THE THREE OF US
ARE FULLY VACCINATED AND HAVE
BEEN FOR SOME TIME AND WE'RE
IN. OUR SOUND SACRAMENTO OFFICE
AT THREE HUNDRED CAPITOL MALL.
AND BEFORE I BEGIN MY
PRESENTATION I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO ADDRESS THE
CURRENT STATEWIDE EXTREME HEAT
CONDITIONS. AND THE PRESSURES
IT IS CREATING ON THE GRID. FOR
IT BEGIN EVEN SAY NOT I WILL
NOTE THAT CAL AYE SO JUST A FEW
MINUTES AGO NOTIFIED ALL OF US
THAT THERE WILL BE A FLEX ALERT
CALLED FOR TOMORROW. I BELIEVE
IT WILL BE BEFORE THE HOURS OF
FIVE AND TEN AND PEOPLE WILL BE
INSTRUCTED TO. ACT ACCORDINGLY
UNDER THE RULES OF THE FIVE
SIMILAR. ON THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEMS OPERATOR AS
WELL AS THE CQC AND THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
ARE CLOSELY MONITORING
TEMPERATURES IN GREAT
CONDITIONS. GIVEN THE
WIDESPREAD HEAT WAVE THAT WILL
CONTINUE OVER MULTIPLE DAYS
CONSUMER. CONSERVATION MAY BE
NEEDED TO HELP STABILIZE THE
GRID AS I JUST NOTED. WHILE THE
CALIFORNIANS MAY BE CALLED TO
CONSERVE POWER AS THEY NOW HAVE
BEEN. THE CAL AYSO BELIEVES. WE
WILL HAVE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT THE GRID THROUGHOUT
THESE CONDITIONS. NEVERTHELESS
WE WILL REMAIN VERY GOOD
JUDGMENT. THIS WEEK'S WILL
RECORD BREAKING TEMPERATURES
ARE REMINDERS THAT THIS SUMMER
IS LIKELY TO BRING MANY HOT
DAYS ACROSS THE WEST AND THAT
MANY OF THE ADJUSTMENTS THE
CPUC CAL AYE SO AND THE CC. PUT
INTO PLACE FOLLOWING LAST
YEAR'S ROLLING OUTAGES WILL
PROBABLY BE NEEDED TO HELP
AVERT OUTAGES SHOULD BE
EXPERIENCED SIMILAR CONDITIONS
IN AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER OF THIS
YEAR. I WILL ADDRESS LATER IN
MY PRESENTATION OUR CURRENT
UNDERSTANDING OF OUR STATE OF
PREPAREDNESS FOR THE EVENT SUCH
AS THESE. WITHOUT TELEVISION WE
I WILL BEGIN MY PRESENTATION.
SINCE JOINING THE CQC I LIKE
YOU HAVE WITNESSED THE IMPACTS
OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES PS PS
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFFS AND LAST AUGUST AS ROLLING
OUTAGES HAVE HAVE ON
CALIFORNIANS. THESE EVENTS ARE
DEFINED AND PRIORITIZE MY HAVE
DEFINED AND PRIORITIZED MUCH OF
OUR WORK AT THE C. P. U. C.
OVER THE LAST YEAR. THESE ARE
MATTERS THAT CUT ACROSS THE
CORE THE CQC'S MISSION TO
ENSURE SAFE RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE UTILITY SERVICES.
GIVEN THAT I WILL BE FOCUSING
MY PRESENTATION ON THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN MOST ON OUR
MINDS AND YOURS DURING INSURING
CALIFORNIANS ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A GRID THAT
IS SAFE AND THAT THEY CAN RELY
ON IN THE FACE OF A RAPIDLY
CHANGING CLIMATE. I OVER MY
BRIEF UPDATES ON OUR EFFORTS TO
DRIVE UTILITIES TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF IT
DOES AND OUR EFFORTS TO ENSURE
RELIABILITY THIS SUMMER. I WILL
THEN PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON OUR
WORK TO GUARANTEE THE ONGOING
RELIABILITY OF THE GRID FOR THE
FUTURE WITHOUT COMPROMISING OUR
STATE'S AMBITIOUS AND NECESSARY
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS. I WELCOME YOUR
ENGAGEMENT AND COLLABORATION ON
THESE ISSUES AS THESE AS THEY
ARE MATTERS THAT REQUIRE
WIDESPREAD EFFORTS AMONG ALL OF
THIS. WITH REGARD TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS AS YOU
ALL WELL KNOW SHUTTING POWER-
OFF TO AVOID CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES CREATES A MAJOR
DISRUPTION FOR THE PUBLIC AND
CREATE SICK AND CAN CREATE-SIGNIFICANT SAFETY. CONCERNS
FOR EVERYONE. WITH THIS
UNDERSTANDING WE HAVE MADE VERY
CLEAR TO THE STATE'S INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS MUST BE
USED AS A MEASURE OF LAST
RESORT WITH WILDFIRE FOUR MILE
FIVE WILDFIRES SKEWS ME
MITIGATION AND EACH YEAR. THEY
MUST WORK TO REDUCE THE SCOPE
DURATION AND FREQUENCY OF THE
PS PS EVENTS. SYSTEM JUST
DISASTROUS POWER SHUT OFFS OF
TWENTY NINETEEN THE UTILITIES
HAVE MADE IMPROVEMENTS DUE IN
NO SMALL PART TO OUR AGGRESSIVE
AND DEEP REACHING OVERSIGHT OF
THEIR CORRECTIVE ACTION AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
POWERSHOT. GUIDELINES AND RULES
WHEN I SAY WE I WILL ALSO
INCLUDE IN THAT THE- CAL THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE STOP
SKEWS ME THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. AND CAL.
FIVE WE HAVE BRIEFED. OUT YOU
BEFORE ON OUR VARIOUS ACTIONS
BUT SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN WE
HAVE ADOPTED TWO SETS OF
UPDATES AND ENHANCEMENTS TO THE
POWERSHOT GUIDELINES TO DRIVE
UTILITIES TO IMPROVE THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS AND COORDINATION
WITH THE IMPACTED LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TRIBES AND MULTIPLE
CUSTOMERS. AND TO TAKE
APPROACHES THAT REDUCE THE
SCOPE FREQUENCY AND DURATION OF
OUTAGES IF CALLED. WE HAVE
FOCUSED TARGETED ATTENTION I.
P. GENIES ACTION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND SCE'S ACTION IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE UTILITIES
UNDER PERFORMANCE IN THOSE
YEARS. WE HAVE ALSO BEEN VERY
FOCUSED ON ENSURING COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS ARE
CONVENIENTLY LOCATED IMPROVING
HOW THEY IDENTIFY AND
COMMUNICATE WITH THE MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE CUSTOMERS AND
SPEEDING UP AND EXPANDING THEIR
BACKUP PATRICK PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT THEIR CUSTOMERS DURING
A P. S. P. S. OF THAT. WE HAVE
ALSO ISSUED A REQUIREMENT FOR
THE COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS TO
INSTALL SEVENTY TWO HOUR BACKUP
POWER TO ENSURE THE PROVISIONS
OF ESSENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES IN THE POWER SHUT OFF.
IN IN POWER SHUT OFF IN THIS.
TWENTY TWENTY WAS A VERY LONG
FIRE SEASON AND CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCED A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF POWER SHUT OFFS BY
THEIR UTILITIES. WELL THE
NUMBER OF THE P. S. P. S.
DEFENSE WENT UP THE NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS OUTAGES HOURS HOWEVER
WENT DOWN BOTH PG&E AND EDISON
REDUCED OUTAGE HOURS IN TWENTY
TWENTY. LOOKING AHEAD TO THIS
YEAR AFTER A DRY WINTER AND
WARM SPRING THE STATE IS LIKELY
IN STORE FOR A LONG AND VERY
DIFFICULT FIRE SEASON. CCL SEN
IN FACT I HAS ALREADY- THIS
WEEK NOTIFIED CUSTOMERS OF A
POP UP POSSIBLE PS PS IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. AS WE MOVE INTO
THE FIRE WILDFIRE SEASON AND
BEYOND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
SPURRING CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE UTILITIES
EXECUTION OF PSP ESTEVEZ AND
INDEED REDUCING THE IMPACTS ON
CUSTOMERS AND THESE EFFORTS
HAVE BEEN BOLSTERED. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER BY OUR
PARTNERS- YES AND CAL FIGHTER.
WITH REGARD TO THE ACTIONS WE
HAVE TAKEN TO HELP ENSURE
RELIABILITY OF OUR ELECTRIC
SYSTEM FOR CALIFORNIANS THIS
SUMMER FIRST I WANT TO EXPRESS
MY APPRECIATION TO THE
COLLEAGUES IN THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR
PRESENT BEFORE YOU LAST MONTH.
ON THE STATUS OF OUR READINESS
FOR THE SUMMER. YOUR OVERSIGHT
AND PARTNERSHIPS HAVE BEEN
CRUCIAL TO OUR ON GOING EFFORTS.
GIVEN THAT WE RECENTLY
PRESENTED I WILL NOT SPEND A
GREAT DEAL OF TIME ON THIS-
ELEMENT AS YOU ARE ALL WELL
APPRISED OF OUR ACTIVITIES
HOWEVER AS I NOTED EARLIER AS
WE HEARD IN AS WE HEAD INTO THE
HOT AND DRY SUMMER. AS IS UPON
US NOW WE ARE REMINDED THAT
MOTHER NATURE CAN BE
UNPREDICTABLE AND INDEED
UNFORGIVING. A CHANGING CLIMATE
IS MAKING EXTREME WEATHER
EVENTS MORE FREQUENT AND SEVERE.
WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF A HEAT
WAVE IN JUNE AND SOME OF THE
STATE'S RESERVOIRS ARE AT
HISTORIC LOWS AND SNOW PACK IS
ESSENTIALLY ZERO PERCENTAGE OF
THE AVERAGE FOR THIS TIME OF
YEAR. WE MUST AND ARE
RESPONDING TO THESE CHANGING
CONDITIONS BY INCREASING.
COORDINATION WITH OUR SISTER
AGENCIES LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
UTILITY GENERATORS PROJECT
DEVELOPERS DEMAND RESPONSE
PROVIDERS AND LARGE INDUSTRIAL
CUSTOMERS AND WE ARE
AGGRESSIVELY MONITORING WEATHER
CONDITIONS AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. AS I STATED IN OUR
MAIN OVERSIGHT HEARING THOUGH
NO ONE CAN PREDICT WHETHER AND
RESOURCE CONDITIONS WITH A 100%
CERTAINTY WE KNOW WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN A STRONGER
POSITION THIS YEAR THAN LAST
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO KEEP
YOU APPRISED OF OUR VIEW ON
THIS CHANGES AS THE SUMMER
PROGRESSES. WHAT WE HADN'T
NECESSARILY LASER FOCUSED ON
RELIABILITY FOR THE SUMMER AND
NEXT ARE PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE'S
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE CONTINUES
FORWARD AND WILL ONLY
ACCELERATE IN THE MONTHS AND
YEARS TO COME. THE CLIMATE
CHANGE INDUCED EVENTS OF LAST
AUGUST ONLY FURTHER
CRYSTALLIZED THE NEED TO BUILD
A MORE RELIABLE GRID. BY WAY OF
A ZERO CARBON RESOURCE. THE
OUTAGES LAST SUMMER WHEN AN
ACCEPTABLE. BUT A SILVER LINING
HAS BEEN THAT IT HAS FURTHER
RESULT FOR FURTHER TO OUR
RESOLVE TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF TENS OF MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS. TO POWER THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND TO LEAD THE FIGHT
AGAINST CATASTROPHIC CLIMATE
CHANGE. THIS COMMITMENT IS
REFLECTED IN OUR LONGER TERM
RELIABILITY AND PROCUREMENT
PLANNING. OVER THE MEDIUM AND
LONGER TERM THE CPUC MUST
ENSURE THAT ALL LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES UNDER OUR JURISICTION
ARE PROCURING ENOUGH NEW
RESOURCES TO MEET INCREASED
DEMAND FROM CLIMATE CHANGE TO
DO SHORT. EXTREME HEAT EVENTS
AND INCREASED ELECTRIFICATION
OF OUR TRANSPORTATION AND
BUILDING SECTORS. THOSE
RESOURCES MUST BE AVAILABLE TO
MEET DEMAND AT ALL HOURS
INCLUDING THE SUMMER EVENING
HOURS AS A SOLAR GENERATION IS
DECREASING AT A FASTER RATE
THAN THE ELECTRICITY DEMAND.
FOR THE CBC MUST ENSURE THAT
THESE NEW RESOURCES THEMSELVES
SUPPORT OUR CLIMATE GOALS. TO
MEET THE STATE'S FUTURE
LIABILITY NEEDS WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF ORDERING ELEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS. INCREASE IN
PROCUREMENT OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS AS PART OF OUR INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING PROCEEDING.
THIS WILL RESULT IN A
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER PLANNING
RESERVE MARGIN THEN WE HAVE
REQUIRED OVER THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS IN ANTICIPATION OF
INCREASED WEATHER RELATED
STRESSES ON OUR GRID. ELEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS
IS IN ADDITION TO THE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF NEW
NET QUALIFYING CLEAN ENERGY
RESOURCES THAT WILL COME ONLINE
BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AS A RESULT OF THE PRIOR CPUC
ACTIONS THIS INCLUDES WIND
SOLAR BATTERY STORAGE AND SOLAR
PLUS STORAGE. WELL THE PURPOSE
OF THE NEW PROCUREMENT IS
PRIMARILY RELIABILITY TO
REPLACE RETIREMENT OF DIAVEL
CANYON NUCLEAR POWER PLANT AND
THE ONCE THROUGH COOLING UNITS
THAT. ALSO SUPPORTS OUR STATE'S
LONG TERM GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTION GOALS.
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARD TO
REPLACEMENT OF DAY OUT OF
CANTON CANYON WE WILL REQUIRE
THE LOAD SERVING ENTITIES TO
PROCURE AT LEAST TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS FOR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR THAT COMES FROM
FIRM ZERO EMISSION RESOURCES.
THIS IS IN ADDITION TO THE
LARGE AMOUNT OF ZERO EMISSION
PROCUREMENTS THAT HAS ALREADY
TAKEN PLACE OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS IN ANTICIPATION OF THE
DIAVEL RETIREMENT. FINALLY
LOOKING AHEAD THE COMMISSION IS%
EVALUATED AND STRONGLY INCLINED
TO ADOPT A DECISION LATER THIS
YEAR A THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
METRIC TONS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS TARGETS IN THE
ELECTRICITY SECTOR BY TWENTY
THIRTY ONE. FURTHER
ACCELERATING OUR PATH TO ZERO
CARBON ELECTRIC SYSTEM. WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE INVITATION TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY AND TO ALLOW
ME TO ADDRESS YOU. ON ON A
SUBSET OF CRITICAL ISSUES THAT
THE CPUC IS CURRENTLY
ADDRESSING AND I AND MY
COLLEAGUES ARE HERE AND WE ARE
HONORED TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MR VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR A PRESENTATION
I KNOW THAT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE QUESTIONS
FOR YOU BUT IT'S- MY PLEASURE
BEFORE WE MOVE TO QUESTIONS FOR
THE COMMITTEE TO INTRODUCE THE
ACTING DIRECTOR AND- YET.
KEEPING OUR- OF THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR PRESENTATION
WELCOME TO YOUR NEW POSITION.
AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN HOLDEN.
BOB GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
HOLDEN THAT MEMBERS OF THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS AMY IF HE COULD GO
AND I HAVE BEEN DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE WITH
ME HERE TODAY ARE GOING TO
SERVE OUR IDENTITY FOR ENERGY
SOURCE ON SEN WHY CAN'T PEOPLE
WANT TO COMMUNICATIONS AND
DARWIN WHAT. ARE MY CHEAP
COUNCIL. ON MAY TENTH I WAS BY
THE OFFICE TO PAY. LEAVE AND
SOME OF THERE. APPOINTED
ALTHOUGH I'M NEW TO THIS
POSITION I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE FIRSTHAND
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATES OFFICES
WORK AND ADVOCACY OVER THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS. AS A CHARLIE THE
COMMISSION'S LEGAL DIVISION AND
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE AND
MISSIONARY BISON. THERE'S
NOTHING MORE REWARDING THAN
BEING TASKED TO RUN AN
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES A
STRONG VOICE FOR UTILITY
CUSTOMERS. I'M PROUD TO SAY
THAT OVER THE PAST YEAR THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
CONTINUED ITS STRONG ADVOCACY
WHICH CLOSELY HERE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDERS
HELP CALIFORNIANS ADVANCE ITS
GOALS TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY IN THE FACE
OF THE PUBLIC NINETEENTH AND
THEM. OUR ADVOCACY CONTINUED TO
HELP INSURE THAT EVERYONE
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ZIP CODE.
HAS ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE SAFE
AND RELIABLE UTILITY SERVICES.
WE PROVIDED IN ADVANCE AND IT
COPIES OF BOTH PROGRAM REPORT
IN A SLIGHT DEATH HOWEVER IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME- JUST
ADDRESS SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
OF THESE DOCUMENTS WHICH YOU
CAN REVIEW ACTUALLY FRAZIER.
OUR MISSION IS TO ADVOCATE FOR
THE LOWEST POSSIBLE UTILITY
RATES CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMERS
CONSISTENT WITH SAFETY
RELIABILITY AND THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOAL. RECEIVE
THIS MISSION OUR TOP PRIORITIES
R. ONE IS SURE THAT WE KNOW HOW
THE PROCESS ANYONE PROPOSE
UTILITY PROGRAM PROJECT LIKE
IMPACT FASTER IS MONTHLY BILLS.
TO ADVOCATE FOR THE THIRTY
SPEAKS OUT ON THE BOAT WHEN
THEY FAIL TO MANAGE THEIR
SYSTEMS SAFELY AND RELIABLY.
AND THREE HELP ADVANCE. THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
LAST YEAR PURCHASED IN THE HUNT
AND NINETY SIX PROCEEDINGS FIVE
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT
MEETINGS AT THE CTC YOU SEE. AN
SUCCESSFULLY INTERACTED WITH
THE PUBLIC IN OTHERS OVER A
THOUSAND TIMES. AND PLEASE
REPORT THAT WE SAFE
CALIFORNIANS MORE THAN THREE
POINT HREE BILLION DOLLARS A
LOWER UTILITY REVENUES AND
AVOID IT. OPERATING CRISIS LAST
YEAR. PUT ANOTHER WAY FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THAT REPAIRS INVESTED IN
OUR ORGANIZATION THEY RECEIVED
OVER SEVENTY SEVEN DOLLARS IN
RETURN. OUR ADVOCACY EFFORTS TO
ACHIEVE THE BEST VALUE FOR THE
CONSUMERS IT'S NEVER BEEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THIS PAST YEAR.
AS WITH THE MISSION AND THE
STATE AS A WHOLE ADDRESS THE
NEED TO MAINTAIN THEM PROVIDE
SEXUAL XLT SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIANS IN THE FACE OF
SHELTER IN PLACE. WILDFIRES AND
POWERSHOW OFFS WHEN THE LAW OF
TIME AND INTERNET SERVICE. OUR
EFFORTS HAVING BURKE DEATH.
FROM ENERGY. THE REST HAVING
THEIR SERVICE DESK. DUE TO NON
DURING THE CAN. SUPPORTING THE
USE OF. GENERATORS AND
PRIORITIZING MY COULD BE
INCENTIVES TO HELP KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON FOR COMMUNITIES
SUBJECT TO THE ENERGY STATION.
SUPPORTING INCREMENTAL ALREADY
RESOURCES. FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO SOME OF
THE LIABILITY NEEDS. REQUIRING
WIRELESS PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE
AT LEAST SEVENTY TWO HOURS THE
FACT THAT OUR CUSTOMERS IN HIGH
FIRED BRADBURY IS CONNECTED TO
A POWER SHORTAGES. POWER
OUTAGES. RECOMMENDING THAT
WIRELINE BROADBAND SPEED
INCLUDED IN THE UNIVERSAL
LIFELINE TELEPHONE SERVICE
PROGRAM AND RECOMMENDING THAT
THE WATER REVENUE ADJUSTMENT
MECHANISM SURCHARGE ELIMINATED.
THAT'LL LEVEL USED TO CUSTOMER
BILLS BY 10220% I HOPE IS VERY
BRIEF OF PRESENTATION SHOWS
THAT DESPITE THE CHALLENGES OF
THE PAST YEAR. THE PUBLICADVOCATE'S OFFICE THE
SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATED ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
AS THE STATE REOPENS WILL
CONTINUE TO SAFELY MEET OUR
WORK LIVES AND OPERATIONAL
NEEDS ASSISTANCE WITH THE
STATE'S WORK HARD WORK
COLLISON'S. WITH THIS. I'D LIKE
TO INCLUDE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY. UP ON SLIDES PLAN OF
ARTS LIKE THAT WAS PROVIDED TO
YOU I HAVE MY CONTACT
INFORMATION AND I WELCOME YOU
YOUR QUESTIONS AND- YELL OUT AT
THIS POINT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND I'D LIKE TO I'D LIKE TO
THANK BOTH OF YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS THIS AFTERNOON.
AND CERTAINLY- WE WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH BOTH
OF YOU AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THIS HEARING WITH QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. BUT I
THOUGHT I WOULD- KIND OF START
OFF IF I COULD WITH SOME
COMMENTS AND MORE DIRECTLY.
FOCUSED TOWARDS THE CPUC SO
PRESIDENT BASHER- I JUST LIKE
TO- WILL REALLY RAISE A I THINK
A ISSUE THAT IS WHAT I WOULD
CONSIDER TO BE MORE OF A
STRUCTURAL ISSUE. AND THAT IS
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE CPUC- FOR
THE MOST PART WE WORK IN
COORDINATION AND I'M GRATEFUL
FOR THAT PARTNERSHIP AND U. S.
PRESIDENT- HAVING CONTINUE TO
BE AN ABSOLUTE GEM TO WORK WITH
PROFESSIONAL AND TIMELY AND
RESPONSES TO OUR QUESTIONS IN
OUR INQUIRY. BUT THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN THERE IS A
DISCONNECT WITH THE CPC. FOR
INSTANCE WHEN THE CPUC DOES NOT
ENGAGE WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
A PUBLIC MATTER ON BILLS THAT
GREATLY IMPACT YOUR WORK. WE
LOOK TO YOU AS EXPERTS WHEN
YOUR VOICE IS MISSING. FROM
THAT DIALOGUE WE SUFFER.
ADDITIONALLY WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSES A MEASURE.
THAT PROVIDES CLEAR DIRECTION
EXPECTATIONS TO THE CPUC. BUT
THEN AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THAT MEASURE THOSE DIRECTIVES
ARE NORD THAT ALSO ROADS THE
RELATIONSHIP. THE ISSUE IT'S
SIMPLY JUST A COMMENT. BUT WHAT
I HOPE YOU TAKE HEART. TAKE TO
HEART ESPECIALLY AND
IMPLEMENTING THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTIVES AS WE GO FORWARD IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE DO HAVE
THAT RELATIONSHIP. THAT
FOSTER'S- HONESTY AND AS WE
DEAL WITH DIFFICULT ISSUES IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE GET
PUBLIC INPUT FROM THE CPSC TO
HELP GUIDE OUR DECISION MAKING.
AND AS I SAID LIKEWISE WHEN WE
DO PUT FORTH CLEAR DIRECTIVES
THE CPC IS TIMELY AND ACTING
UPON THEM. SO I JUST OFFER THAT
UP FOR SOME INITIAL COMMENTS- I
KNOW THAT A LOT OF THE SPECIFIC
THINGS THAT YOU BROUGHT UP. IN
YOUR PRESENTATION MEMBERS MAY
HAVE QUESTIONS- WHETHER IT'S ON
A PS PS EVENTS SUMMER READINESS
OUR OUR PROCUREMENT STRATEGIES
GOING FORWARD- BUT- LET ME JUST
SAY AS I SAID BEFORE ENJOY
WORKING WITH YOU. BUT WE DO
FIND THAT WE HAVE SOME TIME
WHERE ARE WE DON'T GET THE
PERFORMANCE THAT WE THINK WE
SHOULD BE GETTING FROM THE CEBU
CITY SO. WITH THAT- I WILL TOO
IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS-
BECAUSE LIKE RESPOND TO THAT
I'M- HAPPY TO. AND THEN I'LL
TURN TO OTHER MEMBERS. YES
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND AND I'M- I THINK YOU
KNOW BY MANNER AND I HOPE
ACTION THAT- I AM VERY
DISHEARTENED TO HEAR THAT THAT-
YOUR CONCERNS AND THAT I'M SURE
OF OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
PERHAPS OTHER MEMBERS-
REGARDING OUR LACK OF
ENGAGEMENT ON BILLS THAT ARE
BEFORE YOU. AS WELL AS- THOSE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTIVES THAT WE
HAVE NOT ADHERED TO IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION I'M VERY
DISHEARTENED AND I WILL DO
EVERYTHING EVERYTHING THAT I
CAN DO TO AND CHANGE THAT
IMMEDIATELY AND I WELCOME ANY
CALL ANY TIME ANY DAY OF THE
WEEK FROM ANY MEMBER. WHO HAS A
CONCERN OR BETTER YET HAS A
QUESTION ABOUT- BILLS OR ABOUT
ANY OF OUR IMPLEMENTATION OF
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTIVES- AND I
THINK MISTER SURE YOU KNOW YOU
AND I HAVE HAD A EXCELLENT-
OPEN RELATIONSHIP. AND I AM
JOHN I HAVE ENJOYED THAT WITH
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE BOTH THIS COMMITTEE
AND OTHERS SO I APOLOGIZE
PERSONALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY
ON BEHALF OF THE CPUC FOR-
ANYTHING THAT WE HAVE IGNORED
OR IN ANY COMMUNICATION THAT WE
HAVE BEEN LACKING IN AND AS I
SAID I WILL DO EVERYTHING
CORRECT THAT AND I APOLOGIZE TO
YOU MISTER CHAIR. WHAT IT NO
APOLOGY NECESSARY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO BUILD ON
THE RELATIONSHIP AND AS YOU
SAY. WE HAVE A VERY GOOD ONE
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO- US
COLLABORATING BUT IT WAS THAT
SIMPLE GIVEN THE NATURE OF THIS
HEARING I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT- AND IT'S NOT JUST.
ANYTHING NECESSARILY NOW IT IS
SORT OF INSTITUTIONAL AND
SYSTEMIC THROUGH THE CPC OVER
AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME.
THERE ALSO BEEN MORE RECENT
ISSUES AROUND DIRECT ACCESS AND
LEGISLATION THAT WAS ADDRESSING
DIRECT ACCESS AND HOW. SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WERE CALLED FOR
WERE NOT NECESSARILY
IMPLEMENTED OUT OF THE ACTION
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN REGARDS
TO THAT. PARTICULAR BILL AND-
THERE BEEN OTHER INSTANCES I
THINK THAT OTHERS. MAY HAVE
THEIR OWN PARTICULAR.
REMEMBRANCES OF THAT- THEY THEY
CARRY WITH THEM BUT I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE. AS
WE'RE BOTH PUBLIC INTO ENTITIES
THAT WE HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS
IN A WAY WHERE. WE'VE HEARD
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME SOME OF
THE CONCERNS WELL WE HEAR
OFTEN. SOME OF THE CONCERNS IN
TERMS OF THE SLOW. MOVEMENT
YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO CHANGE IT TO
THE BEST OF YOUR ABILITY BUT I
THINK THAT THERE CONTINUES TO
BE SOME. QUESTIONS OUT THERE
AND AREAS THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
PARTNER WITH YOU. IN YOUR
ENDEAVORS IN YOUR EFFORT TO
ADDRESS THOSE THOSE KIND OF
ISSUES. ARE GOING TO TURN TO A
THINK. OF MR TANG YOU HAD YOUR
MICROPHONE UP FIRST AND-
MURATSUCHI. IN THE MARKET.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
RAISING THAT POINT ACTUALLY WAS
THE VERY POINT I WAS PLANNING
ON RAISING SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR COMMENTS
AND- THIRD TO MADAM CHAIR WHO I
ALSO HAVE A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH DATING BACK
TO HER- PREVIOUS SERVICE IN OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT- IT IS. IT IS
UNFORTUNATE- TO ECHO THE EXACT
SAME EXPERIENCE I HAD WITH ONE
OF MY- PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
THAT WAS- DEALING WITH ENERGY
EFFICIENCY- TRYING TO. FIND
USES FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCY
MONEY WHICH THE UTILITIES
CHARGE US THE RATEPAYERS WHICH
WE PAY FOR. AND UNFORTUNATELY
CONTINUES OVER TIME TO NOT BE
SPENT IN MORE TALK ABOUT HOW
MUCH IS NOT BEING SPENT WE'RE
TALKING UPWARDS OF. COULD BE
FIFTY TO ALMOST A HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR OF AGAIN
RATEPAYER MONEY WHICH IS BEING
USED FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCY. AT
A TIME WHEN WE'VE HAD TO SHUT
OFF OUR POWER BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH POWER- IN THE
STATE- IN YET YOUR AGENCY- SEEM
TO FEEL MORE IN I MEAN I JUST I
DON'T BELIEVE THIS REFLECTIVE
OF YOUR FEELINGS. MADAM CHAIR
BUT MORE THE AGENCIES HOW- THE
AGENCIES SEEM TO FEEL LIKE THIS
WAS THEIR MONEY NOT THE RATE
PAYERS MONEY- IT SEEMS TO BE A
VERY UNFORTUNATE. THAT RATHER
THAN. FIGURING OUT HOW WE COULD
DEPLOY THIS MONEY. INTO ITS
INTENDED PURPOSE WHICH WAS
ENERGY EFFICIENCY- IT BECAME A
POLITICAL TURF WAR. WHICH TO ME
IS ABSOLUTELY NOT AN
APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR THE
AGENCY. OR FRANKLY IS IT IS A
WASTE OF TIME FOR ALL OF US
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
ENERGY TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON.
AND WE COULD DEFINITELY USE-
SMARTLY- ENERGY EFFICIENCY
RESOURCES DEPLOYED AROUND THE
STATE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PRECIOUS ENERGY THAT WE DOOR
PRODUCING IS BEING USED AS
EFFICIENTLY. AS POSSIBLE- SO I
WOULD REALLY URGE YOU AS YOU
HAVE A VERY VERY DIFFICULT JOB
AND I UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT
THE JOB THIS IS MY OFFICE IS
JUST DOWN THE STREET FROM YOUR
OFFICE- OF REALLY. TURNING
AROUND. THIS AGENCY THAT THE
AGENCY. IS NOT THERE TO SERVE
ITSELF BUT TO REALLY SERVE THE
RATE PAYERS AND THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE. AND THAT AS IT'S
TASKED WITH OVERSEEING FUNDS
THAT CLEARLY HAVEN'T BEEN USED
FOR WHATEVER REASON- IF THE
AGENCY CAN'T SOMEHOW FIGURE
OUT. HOW TO DEPLOY THESE
RESOURCES THAT I'D WISH THEY'D
GET OUT OF THE WAY THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE ARE ABLE TO
DO THAT. AND I THINK THAT IS-
WHAT I JUST TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE
OF WHAT THE CHAIR IS TALKING
ABOUT JUST BE VERY VERY
SPECIFIC. IT WAS- EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTING- INTERACTION BUT
UNFORTUNATELY HAS BEEN
INDICATIVE OF MY EXPERIENCE. IN
WORKING WITH THE- WITH YOUR
AGENCY IT PREDATES YOU. PRE
DATES SHARE PICKER- YOU KNOW
AND GOES BACK TO EVEN CHECK
TV'S TIMES I DON'T I DON'T LOOK
AT IT AS- A REFLECTION OF-
REALLY ANY OF THE COMMISSIONERS
IN ESSENCE BUT- UNFORTUNATELY
MORE OF A REFLECTION. OF THE
CULTURE OF THE ORGANIZATION
WHICH I KNOW YOU HAVE A
CHALLENGE TO TRY AND TURN
AROUND. BURKE IT IS MY HOPE.
THAT AS YOU HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN TURNING AROUND
OTHER AGENCIES THAT YOU ALSO BE
ABLE TO TURN AROUND THIS
AGENCY. BECAUSE I THINK IT HAS.
LOST TRACK OF ITS MISSION. AND
LOST TRACK OF WHOM IT IS
SUPPOSED TO SERVE. AND SO I
JUST IMPLORE YOU. TO KNOW THAT
AS YOU PUSH AND MAKE CHANGES AS
YOU'VE DONE IN SO MANY OF OTHER
AGENCIES IN YOUR CAPACITIES TO
ENSURE THAT THE COMMISSION IS
SERVING THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE. THAT I MYSELF AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT AND WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE OF CHANGES AS YOU
CHOOSE TO MAKE THEM TO ENSURE
THAT THE COMMISSION HAS THAT
MISSION AT HEART. THAT IS
ENSURING THAT RATEPAYER MONEY
IS GOING TO WHERE IT'S INTENDED
TO GO RATHER THAN SITTING
AROUND GATHERING DUST WHEN HE
NEEDS TO BE CRITICALLY DEPLOYED
SO WITH THAT I JUST THINK THE
CHAIR FOR HIS OPENING COMMENTS
BECAUSE I THINK THEY ARE VERY
REFLECTIVE. OF THE MINDSET OF
NOT ONLY THIS COMMITTEE BUT
REALLY OUR OUR ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU.
MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I HAVE A SEARS THE QUESTIONS-
FIRST OF ALL IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- THE. THE
BASIC LESSON THAT- I. BELIEVE
THEY THE PC HAS ADMITTED TO
LEARNING FROM LAST YEAR'S
ROLLING BLACKOUTS. WAS THAT-
THE- RELEVANT AGENCIES THE P.
C. THE ENERGY COMMISSION THE I
ALSO DID NOT SUFFICIENTLY PLAN
FOR THE EXTREME HEAT. ARM IS
ACT IS THAT CORRECT. MEMBER YES
WE- DIDN'T THE THREE OF US
KALISTO CC AND CPUC-
INDIVIDUALLY AND COLLECTIVELY-
IF YOU ARE A ROOT CAUSE
ANALYSIS FOUND THAT THERE WERE
SEVERAL THINGS THAT FRANKLY WE
NEEDED TO DO BETTER AND- THEY
WERE BOTH- THE ENERGY DEMAND
FORECASTING WHICH I THINK
YOU'RE REFERRING TO INTO IN
TERMS OF YOUR QUESTION.
RESOURCE PLANNING AND
CONTINGENCY CONTINGENCY PLAN
INCLUDING DEVELOPING A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF OUR SUPPLY
SIDE TRENDS IN NEIGHBORING
STATES AND HOW THIS WILL
IMPACT- CALIFORNIA'S ACCESS TO
IMPORTED ENERGY- OVER TIME SO
THERE WERE SEVERAL THEY WERE
ACTUALLY FOR ROOT CAUSE
ANALYSIS ROOT CAUSES IN OUR
ANALYSIS THAT WERE FOUND AMONG
THEM THAT'S CORRECT FORECASTING
WAS ON ONE OF THE ISSUES
FORECASTING IN TERMS OF DEMAND.
AND SUPPLY. SO IN IN IN TERMS
OF THE FORECASTING FOR THE-
DEMAND- GOING INTO THE FUTURE-
DO YOU DO YOU HAVE LIKE A- YOU
KNOW- WEATHER EXPERTS THAT ARE
THAT ARE PROVIDING PROJECTIONS
FOR YOU IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH
WORSE THE EXTREME HEAT
CONDITIONS THE AND THE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
EXPECTED TO GET. WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE CAL AYSO AND
SEE SEE THEY ALSO HAVE EXPERTS
FORECASTING EXPERTS AS WELL
AND- WE FORECAST BUT THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MOST OF THE
FORECASTING IS ON. ON THE
SHOULDERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION BUT- WE ALL
HAVE VERY IMPORTANT MODELING
THAT WE FOLLOW THAT AND HELPS
US IN TERMS OF ARE ARE PLANNING
FOR FUTURE PROCUREMENT. AND
FUTURE THEREFORE FUTURE DEMANDS
OF ON THE SYSTEM SO. WE HAVE
THE INTEGRATED PLANNING
RESOURCE PROCESS WHICH WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE INTERIM- I. R.
P. PROCESS NOW IN FACT WE WILL
BE THERE'S A PROPOSED DECISION
THAT'S OUT ON THE STREET AND
THE COMMISSION WILL BE VOTING
ON IT AT THE END OF THE MONTH.
BUT IT IS ONE OF THE TOOLS THAT
WE HAVE WHERE IN- WE TAKE THE
FORECASTING AND MODELLING. AND
A LOT OF PUBLIC INPUT ON AND
DECIDE WHAT ARM IS NEEDED FOR-
FUTURE PROCUREMENT AND TO MEET
THE DEMENTIAS AT OUR FORECAST
IT. CURRENTLY THE I. R. IN THE
INTERIM I R. P. IS REVIEWING
THE YEARS TWENTY TWENTY THREE
THROUGH TWENTY. TWENTY SIX.
OKAY SO GET A GIVEN DAY THE
CURRENT I. R. P. GOING OUT TO
TWENTY TWENTY SIX DO YOU HAVE
LIKE EXTREME HEAT PROJECTIONS.
UP THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY SIX
WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE MODEL ON IS
DEMAND WHICH IS WHICH IS DRIVEN
BY WEATHER CLIMATE CHANGE
WEATHER CONDITIONS AND-
POPULATION- TIMES DURING THAT
THE DATE FOR EXAMPLE- CAL AYE
SO DTERMINES. WHERE THAT
DEMAND USUALLY LIES AND WE
SPEAK YOU'LL HEAR SPEAK ABOUT
THE NEXT PEAK AND THE- PEAK
HOURS ACTUALLY THOSE HAVE
CHANGED RECENTLY AGAIN WE ALL
BELIEVE THAT IT'S DUE TO OUR
SEVERE CLIMATE CHANGE AND- THE
NEXT PEAK NOW HAS MOVED FROM-
SAY THE LATER HOURS OF SEVEN TO
THE LATER HOURS OF NINE PM. SO
WE NOW ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
HOURS BETWEEN FOUR PM AND NINE
PM AND AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE-
DECREASING SUPPLY PARTICULARLY
IN SOLAR- IN THOSE HOURS WHEN
THE SUN IS SETTING SO WE HAVE
TO BE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
PLENTY OF RESOURCES TO MAKE UP
FOR THE DECREASE IN SUPPLY NOW
THAT'S ALL PART OF OUR
FORECASTING AND OUR MODELING
THAT- ON C. B. U. C. DOES THE
CDC MOST IMPORTANTLY DOES. AND
IT'S ALSO INFORMED. BY AND THE
CALLOUS SO. IN IN TERMS OF
FORTY AND PLANNING I MEAN IT IS
THAT THE- FAIR TO SAY THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE FORECASTING. THE
EXTREME HEAT CONDITIONS TO GET
BACK INTO IT TO GET WORSE
RATHER THAN BETTER. WELL WE AND
AGAIN IT'S THE MODELING IN
TERMS OF WHEN. WE MODEL TO
DEMAND AND THAT'S PART OF THE
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF THE
CURRENT I. R. P. IT'S ALSO-
WHAT RESOURCES WERE WILL BE
LEADING THE GRIT AND I THINK I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING REMARKS
ON. THE THAT THE RETIREMENT OF
DIAVEL CANYON NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT WILL BE RETIRING TWEEN.
YEARS TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
SO THAT FOR EXAMPLE IS A
RESOURCE THAT WE ARE MAKING UP
WITH IN OUR RESOURCE PLANNING-
THAT WE'RE DOING CURRENTLY AND
HAVE DONE IN PRIOR YEARS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT BUT IN
TERMS OF THE FORECASTING OF THE-
OF THE WEATHER CONDITIONS AND-
THE THAT THE DEMANDS IN TERMS
OF AIR CONDITIONING BACK THAT
YOU'RE PROJECTING. IS IT FAIR
TO SAY THAT YOU'RE PROJECTING
WORSENING EXTREME HEAT
CONDITIONS RATHER THAN IMPROVE
YEAH YEAH. OKAY YES WE ARE WE
ARE. AND SO YOU A. YOU HAVE
ACTUAL- STUDIES THE DATA IS
PROJECTIONS IN TERMS OF THE
DEGREE OF EXTREME HEAT. ARE
EXPECTED TO BE- WORSENING. I'M
GOING TO ASK- MISTER RANDOLPH
TO ASSIST ME IN BEING MORE
CLEAR WITH MY RESPONSE TO YOU
SIR. AND YOU WANT ONE ANOTHER
FROM THANK YOU PRESIDENT
BASHER- ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERRY
G. PART OF THE PROCESS HERE OUR
FORECAST IS AS PRESIDENT BATRA
SAID- INITIATES AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION- SO THEY WILL
DO THE ORIGINAL DEMAND BOB
FORECASTING BASED ON WHETHER-
SO THE- QUESTION ON HOW WE
ACCOUNT FOR. INCREASED ARM
HEATWAVES INCREASED EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS- THAT'S BAKED
INTO THAT CC'S MODELING AND WE
SHOULD ADDRESS THAT TO THEM TO
GET MORE TECHNICAL- WE NOTE
FROM- THE PAST. SEVERAL YEARS
BUT ESPECIALLY LAST SUMMER-
FROM THE COLD SNAP AND- TEXAS
THIS LAST WINTER- IN THE HEAT
WAVE WE'RE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING WHICH IS YOU KNOW
GOING TO BE RECORD TEMPERATURES
FOR JUNE ACROSS- THE SOUTHWEST
AND PARTS OF CALIFORNIA ON THAT
WE DO HAVE THESE MORE EXTREME
EVENTS THAT WE NEED TO THE PLAN
FOR. I'M ON THE PC SIDE IN THE
MEDIA- OUR FUTURE THE PLAN FOR
THOSE WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE
INCREASED WHAT'S ITS TECHNICAL
TERM BUT RIVER OF REFERRED TO
AS THE PLANNING RESERVE MARGIN-
IN THAT WILL- ENABLE THE SYSTEM
TO RESPOND AND BE READY TO
INSTEAD OF RESPONDING TO A ONE
IN TEN. WHETHER OF THAT- IT
WILL BE CLOSER TO ONE THIRTY
FIVE WEATHER EVENTS ARE FAR
MORE EXTREME- WEATHER EVENT IN
THE SUMMERTIME THAT'S AYE AYE
SHORT TERM- I CHANGE THAT WE'VE
JUST DONE- IN OTHER PROCEEDINGS
WERE LOOKING AT MORE LONG TERM
CHANGES- IN. THE ASSUMPTIONS WE
MAKE AROUND ARE FORECASTING.
OUR THANK YOU SO GAY THAT- YOU
ARE MAKING THE- FORECASTS OR OR
YOU'RE YOU'RE RECEIVING THE
FORECAST FROM THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND YOU'RE MAKING
PLANS ACCORDINGLY IN TERMS OF
THE- THE ENERGY PROCUREMENT-
MANDATE SO YOUR YOUR GIFT ISSUE
TO THE- LOAD SERVING ENTITIES-
I. WONDER WHAT BRING IT BACK TO
MY DISTRICT- MISTER RANDOLPH IT
IS YOU KNOW WELL AND- MS-
BADGER YOU YOU MADE A REFERENCE
TO THE ONCE THROUGH COOLING
PLANTS- I HAVE ONE OF THE ONCE
THROUGH COOLING- PLANTS IN MY
IN MY DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
REDONDO BEACH THEY WERE
PROMISED. IN A FOR TEN YEARS
THAT THE ONCE THROUGH COOLING
WOULD BE SHUT DOWN BY THE END
OF TWENTY TENTY. IT SEEMS
THAT- YOU KNOW EVERY YEAR WHERE
WE'RE HEARING GOT. YOU KNOW I
ANOTHER YEAR OF EXTENSION
ANOTHER OF EXTENSION. WELL WHAT
WHAT IS THE CURRENT PLAN IN
TERMS OF- THE ONES THROUGH-
PULLING SHUTDOWNS THEY WERE
ORIGINALLY SCHEDULED FOR THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY. I'M YES
THANK YOU- THOSE ARE NOW
SCHEDULED- ALL THE- TO SEIZE
ONCE THROUGH COOLING- PLANTS
ARE SCHEDULED NOW TO GO OFFLINE
BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR OKAY. AND IS THERE
IS THERE ANY- ANY ANY GUARANTEE
OR ANY ANY PROVISION THAT THAT
WOULD BE THE LAST EXTENSION. WE
CERTAINLY HOPE SO. DURING LAST
THE TOPIC I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS-
IS THE NET ENERGY METERING-
SUBJECT- AS YOU MAY KNOW WE HAD
A- THE BILL AND IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY- WHERE MANY MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE INCLUDING
MYSELF- HAVE EXPRESSED OUR
FRUSTRATION WITH THE- PUC'S.
AND ACTION- IN IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING THE COST SHIFT ISSUE
WILL. THE NET ENERGY METERING
OF. CAN YOU ASSURE US THAT THE
P. YOU SEE WELL- ACT
EXPEDITIOUSLY- IT'S IT SHOULD
ADDRESS THE COST SHIFTING
ISSUE- THAT THAT EXISTS WITH
THE CURRENT NET ENERGY METERING
SCHEME. YES SIR LET ME ADDRESS
OUR TIME FRAMES ON AND WE HAVE
HAD SOME DELAYS AND I ADMIT TO
THAT- AND FOR WHICH OF. I HAVE
TO APOLOGIZE BUT THE COMMISSION
HAS BEEN WORKING TO MOVE THE
NAM REVISIT PROCEEDING FORWARD-
THIS YEAR THEY'VE WORKED HARD
ON THAT IT IS ON TRACK TO ISSUE
A PROPOSED DECISION ON THE
MATTER BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ARTIE'S JUST TO RUN
THROUGH THE SCHEDULE PARTIES
WILL FILED TESTIMONY IN- THIS
MONTH JUNE AND JULY. THE
COMMISSION WILL HOLD
EVIDENTIARY HEARINGS FROM JULY
TWENTY EIGHTH THROUGH AUGUST
SIX- PARTIES WILL FILE BRIEFS
IN AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER. THE
COMMISSION WILL LIKELY ISSUE A
PROPOSED DECISION THEREFORE IN
DECEMBER THAT WILL BE VOTED ON-
AFTER THE THIRTY DAY PERIOD
WHICH WILL PROBABLY BE IN
JANUARY BUT CERTAINLY RIGHT
RIGHT- AT THAT DEADLINE. SO
THAT'S OUR CURRENT SCHEDULE
FOR- THE NEXT RECEDING WE REFER
TO IT CASUALLY IS AN M. THREE
POINT NO. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE FAIR. THANK YOU.
BARKER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I WANT TO THANK PRESIDENT
BADGER AND YOUR TEAM- FOR BEING
HERE TO TALK TO US AND I WANT
TO START BY X. BY THINKING YOU-
I THINK THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR
BACKUP POWER REQUIREMENT THAT
YOU PUT INTO PLACE THIS YEAR
WAS SO CRITICAL AS YOU I'M SURE
AWARE SENATOR GLAZER INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION THAT I CO AUTHORED
TO DO EXACTLY THAT BECAUSE WE
HAD IT PS PS EVENT IN WHICH WE
HAD NO. AND TELEPHONE
COMMUNICATIONS AVAILABLE WHILE
A WILDFIRE BROKE OUT AND IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE EVACUATION AS
A RESULT WAS REALLY REALLY
CHALLENGING AND OUR
FIREFIGHTERS DID INCREDIBLE JOB
AND EVERYBODY WAS SAFELY
EVACUATED BUT IT REALLY RAISE
THAT ISSUE AND I THINK YOU
ADDRESSING IT AS EXPEDITIOUSLY
AS YOU DID DESERVES INCREDIBLE
CREDIT BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS
WHAT ALL OF US HOPE IF YOU SEE
WILL DO WE SEE A PROBLEM LIKE
THAT ADDRESS IT AND CREATE
EXPECTATIONS THAT WILL KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE FOR SO THANK YOU.
I WANTED TO TOUCH ON SOMETHING
THAT STRUCK ME AS I WAS READING
YOUR ANNUAL REPORT. WHICH WAS
ENFORCEMENT- AS I WAS READING
IT AND I WAS READING
SPECIFICALLY THE SAFETY AND-
FOR SCIENCE. DIVISION THAT
THEY- HAD FORTY SEVEN CITATIONS
THIS YEAR. I BELIEVE WE
PROBABLY HAD MORE THAN FORTY
SEVEN VIOLATIONS IN MY DISTRICT
ALONE- THE TOTAL. NUMBER OF THE
AMOUNT THAT WAS FINED UNDER
THEM WITH LESS THAN THREE
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS IN
STARK COMPARISON TO THE- FIFTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS THAT PG&E
SPENT ON OVERHEAD OUT OF THE
WILD FIRE. FINE SO IF THE DROP
IN THE BUCKET FOR THESE-
UTILITIES AND IT STRUCK ME AS-
REALLY NOT NECESSARILY AS
AGGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
AS I WOULD HOPE TO SEE GIVEN
THE RISKS AND THE COST TO
CALIFORNIANS LIVES IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BEING THEM
THAT ARE RESULTING FROM THE
FAILURE FOR THESE UTILITIES TO
DO WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
SO IF YOU COULD JUST SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW YOU WERE
TRYING TO STEP UP AGGRESSIVE
ENFORCEMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE UTILITIES ARE DOING WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO TO KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE- YES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- FOR THE QUESTION
AND FIRST IF I MAY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS IN TERMS OF
THE SEVENTY TWO. HOUR BACKUP I
REMEMBER WELL WHEN FOLKS I
BELIEVE IT WAS IN LAFAYETTE-
WERE HAD NO. ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE. WITH FIRST
RESPONDERS. AND HAD NO ABILITY
TO UNDERSTAND- WHERE THE FIRE
WAS MOVING IN THERE IN A P. S.
P. S. N. NO CELL SERVICE SO. IT
THAT EXAMPLE AMONG MANY STAYS
VERY CLOSE IN MY MEMORY- I AM
GOING TO TURN TO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR- PETERSON TO GIVE-
SOME OF THE BACKGROUND ON THIS.
SHE PREVIOUSLY HELD THE
POSITION IN OUR- SAFETY
DIVISION HERE AT THE P. UC.
RACHEL YES THANK YOU PRESIDENT
DR OTHER GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
I THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION- I
THINK IN PART WHAT IS-
EXPRESSED IN THE ANNUAL REPORT
THERE MIGHT BE A SLIGHT TIMING
ISSUE AS FAR AS- THE TOTAL
AMOUNT. OF PENALTIES AND
CITATIONS THAT WE HAVE- THERE
WE'VE ISSUED. I'LL JUST NOTE
THAT LIKELY SEPARATE FROM. WHAT
YOU'RE READING THERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. IS A NUMBER OF LARGER
IN FORCE MAKE CASES. FOR
EXAMPLE THE COMMISSION ISSUED
A- TOTAL PENALTIES PACKAGE OF
ONE POINT ONE BILLION AGAINST
PGD. FOR ITS ROLE IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
OF WILDFIRES THAT OCCURRED IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. SO IN ONE
SENSE I THINK SOMETIMES WHEN WE
SPEAK ABOUT CITATIONS WE'RE
SPEAKING ABOUT. THE SMALLER
QUICKER EXPECTATIONS THAT WE
CAN IMPOSE AS STAFF. ON THE
UTILITIES WHICH ARE SEPARATE
FROM THE MUCH LARGER MORE
THOROUGH. AND MORE FINANCIALLY-
SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES THAT THE
COMMISSION. CAN OPPOSE. VOTING
AS AS A MEMBER BY- WITH THAT
NEVER THE LESS I DEFINITELY
TAKE YOUR- AND I TAKE YOUR
QUESTION WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
HARD ON. BUILDING UP OUR
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES THE
COMMISSION ADOPTED AN
ENFORCEMENT POLICY- LAST YEAR
THAT APPLIES COMMISSION. AND
IT'S SIX AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
IVE BEEN WORKING ON ENSURING
THAT ALL OF OUR DIVISIONS
RANGING FROM ELECTRIC AND GAS
TO WATER TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ENERGY. ARE ALL- BUILDING UP
THEIR ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES SO
THAT WE CAN ACT MORE QUICKLY
WHEN- THE OCCASIONS CALL FOR. I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I
UNDERSTAND THE ONE POINT
BILLION I'M REALLY FOCUSED ON
PREVENTION RIGHT THE SMALL
CITATIONS ARE THE ONES THAT
FOCUS ON PREVENTION OF THE
WILDFIRES UNDERSTAND YOU THEN
FINE. AFTER THE WILD FIRES ARE
CAUSED BUT I THINK WE NEED MORE
AGGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT OF THOSE
SMALL CITATIONS THAT WILL
PREVENT WILDFIRES- AND THEN WE
THAT I NOTICED SOMETHING THAT I
THOUGHT WAS VERY EXCITING IN
THE ANNUAL REPORT. WHICH WAS
THE P. JEANNIE M. SAFETY AND
REPORTING MOBILE APP PILOT
PROGRAM AND PART OF WHAT I HAVE
REALLY BEEN FOCUSED ON IS HOW
DO WE GET MORE ESPECIALLY IN
TERRITORIES IS LARGEST P.
JEANNIE. HOW DO WE GET MORE
EYES ON THESE VIOLATIONS SO WE
CAN SEE THEM PREVENT THEM AND
STOP THEM AND SO I THOUGHT THAT
WAS AN INTERESTING. PILOT THE
LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO LAUNCH
THIS SUMMER AND I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS CAN YOU TALK A
LITTLE ABOUT THAT AND THEN TALK
ABOUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN ONCE YOU
GET A CUSTOMER. TO TALK ABOUT A
VIOLATION WHAT IS THE FOLLOW
THROUGH TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
SEEING FROM THE UTILITIES
RESPONSIVENESS SO THAT. AGAIN
WE'RE PREVENTING. WILDFIRES
INCIDENTS I'M GONNA ASK RACHEL
AGAIN WITH HER- FORMER HAPPEN
ON- BECAUSE SHE CAN BE VERY
SPECIFIC ABOUT THIS THANK YOU
YES AND THANK YOU ALSO FOR THE
QUESTION I AGREE I ACTUALLY
QUITE LIKE THAT PROGRAM AND
THE- IDEAS BEHIND IT I HAVE TO
ADMIT ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M NOT-
UP ON THE EXACT STATUS OF IT
BUT WE'LL BE HAPPY TO GET BACK
TO YOUR OFFICE ABOUT THAT- AND
THEN AS FAR AS FOLLOWS THROUGH
THAT IS THE GOAL OF SIXTEEN
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION IS TO
RECEIVE THOSE NOTIFICATIONS
FROM CUSTOMERS ABOUT- A PIECE
OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THEY
NOTICE OR AND OVERHANGING
LIMBS- YOU'RE RIGHT IN THE
FARTHER REACHES OF PG&E SERVICE
TERRITORY. AND BRING IT TO OUR
ATTENTION AND THEN WE WOULD-
FOLLOW UP AS RAPIDLY AS
POSSIBLE- WE DO HAVE A
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM OURSELVES
IN WHICH WE IDENTIFY HAZARDS
THAT ARE MORE URGENT COMPLETE
AT THAT MORE URGENTLY NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED AND WE HAVE A WAY
OF COMMUNICATING THAT STREET TO
FIJI- BUT I WILL TAKE THAT
QUESTION BACK TO OUR STAFF AND
MAKE SURE WE GET AN ANSWER.
THANK YOU WASN'T CLEAR TO ME
THAT YOU WERE ACTUALLY THE ONES
RECEIVING THOSE NOTIFICATIONS.
FROM CUSTOMERS ACTUALLY THINK
THAT. A GOOD POINT OF CARE. AND
YOU'LL BE SEEING THAT NOT JUST
THE TOILET IS THEMSELVES. I'M
SO LASTLY ONE ACTIVE ASK A
QUICK QUESTION REALLY TOUCHING
ON SOMETHING THAT-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. SPOKE
ABOUT EARLIER WHICH IS THE SB
THREE FIFTY GOAL- TO INCREASE
OUR ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND I
NOTICED IN THE REPORT THAT YOU
TALK ABOUT MOVING TOWARD THAT
GOAL BUT DIDN'T ACTUALLY.
CLARIFY WHERE WE ARE IN
ACHIEVING OUR ENERGY EFFICIENCY
IMPROVEMENTS- AND YOU KNOW
EIGHT. I AM AWARE THAT THE I
USE ARE ALSO SPENDING LESS IN
ENERGY EFFICIENCY SO. GIVEN
THAT WE'RE NOT SPENDING AS MUCH
AS ASSEMBLY AVERTING NOTICE WE
KNOW THE I USE AREN'T SPENDING
AS MUCH AS WE WANTED ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. I'M CURIOUS FOR AN
UPDATE ON WHERE WE ARE IN
ACHIEVING THOSE GOALS- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN FOR THE
QUESTION AND I DID APPRECIATE-
MEMBERED TANG'S COMMENTS AS
WELL. HE WAS SPEAKING ABOUT THE
ENERGY IS ENERGY EFFICIENCY
BILL OF LAST YEAR. AND I THINK
NOT TO NOT TO ON THE DEFENSIVE
AT ALL BECAUSE I TAKE. YOUR
CRITICISM VERY VERY WELL. AND I
TAKE IT TO HEART AND I WILL DO
THINGS. OUT OF HOWEVER WE WERE
BEING. SOMEWHAT DRIVEN BY THE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY- GUIDELINES
IF YOU WILL AND WHAT CAN BE
SPENT ON ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
WHAT CANNOT. AND THOSE FUNDS-
CARRY OVER IF THEY'RE NOT USED
IN ONE YEAR THEY DO KERRY TO
THE NEXT. SO THEY'RE NOT LOST
FUNDS BUT OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO
UTILIZE AND AS FULLY. AS
POSSIBLE MANY ASK MISTER
RANDOLPH TO GIVE AN UPDATE ON
THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS.
TO BETTER ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
YEAH AND THANKS AHMED SAID
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION ON THE
SB THREE FIFTY ENERGY
EFFICIENCY GOALS WHICH REQUIRED
A- SET A GOAL OF DOUBLING OF
ENERGY EFFICIENCY. I AM WHAT
I'LL REMIND FOLKS OF IS THAT'S
NOT JUST THE DOUBLING OF ENERGY
EFFICIENCY THAT COMES FROM THE-
RATEPAYER FUNDED PROGRAMS ON
THE DECEIVE YOU SEE OVERSEAS-
BUT ALSO FROM THE- CODES AND
STANDARDS IN OTHER PROGRAMS AT
THE ENERGY COMMISSION OVERSEAS-
AND AS YOU LOOK FORWARD YOU SEE
MORE OF. THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY-
GAINS COMING FROM THOSE CODES
AND STANDARDS PROGRAMS THAN YOU
DO FROM THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY- RATEPAYER FUNDED
PROGRAMS OUT THERE AND THE
REASON WHY YOU SEE A DECREASE
AND TOTAL FUNDING FROM. THE
RATEPAYER FUNDED PROGRAMS IS
THERE'S ALSO STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS- OUT THERE THAT
THE RATEPAYER FUNDED PROGRAMS
TO BE COST EFFECTIVE- AND SO
THAT COMMISSION RUNS-
BIANNUALLY A GOALS AND
POTENTIALS PROGRAM OUT THERE
THAT LOOKS AT THE TOTAL. GOAL
POTENTIAL ENERGY EFFICIENCY
FROM THE RATEPAYER FUNDED
INCENTIVE TYPE PROGRAMS- THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AT THE
COMMISSION- IT HAS. MORE
PROGRAMS GO INTO CODE MEANING
THEY'RE MANDATORY- YOU HAVE
LESS COST EFFECTIVE POTENTIAL-
FOR THOSE- INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE. OUT THERE IN A GOOD
EXAMPLE WOULD BE- WE USE THIS A
LOT OF MY ON- LIGHTING- BECAUSE
THAT WAS A VERY COST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO GET- ENERGY EFFICIENCY
IMPROVEMENT- HOWEVER- BOTH IN
THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL NOW
THAT THERE ARE A VERY- YEAH
VERY SPECIFIC VERY- AGGRESSIVE
LIGHTING- CODES AND STANDARDS
FOR- LED LIGHTS- AND OF LIGHTS
THAT ARE MORE EFFICIENT THAN
THE OLD CONTACT- INCANDESCENT
LIGHTS- OF THOSE HAVE BEEN.
PHASED OUT OF THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THAT WE OVERSEE
BECAUSE THEY NO LONGER NEED
INCENTIVES ARE MANDATED COAT-
AND SO YOU SEE THAT DECREASE
THEIR- IN SO. LONG WAY TO GET
TO YOUR ORIGINAL QUESTION IS
WHERE ARE WE ON THIS SB THREE
FIFTY GOALS- WE ARE NOT ALL ON.
TARGET TO GET TO THOSE GOALS AS
A DOUBLING- RIGHT NOW- IF YOU
LOOK AT IT STRICTLY AS AN
ENERGY EFFICIENCY- PART- BUT
THAT'S A JOINT AGENCY EFFORT
IT'S NOT JUST THE UTILITY SPEND
I DON'T THINK UTILITY SPEND
GOING DOWN. IS WHAT'S KEEPING A
SOFT TARGET HOWEVER ON THE FLIP
SIDE- THIS STATE HAS VERY
AGGRESSIVELY MOVED- TOWARDS
BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION- AND
WE ARE WORKING WITH- OUR SISTER
AGENCY THE CC AND- BEER
RESOURCES BOARD TO LOOK AT THAT
FUEL SWITCHING OF MOVING PEOPLE
FROM. USING NATURAL GAS TO
USING ELECTRICITY- AND HOW THAT
IMPACTS- OUR OVERALL ENERGY
USAGE WHICH IS HOW WE SHOULD BE
DEFINING THIS ENERGY EFFICIENCY
GOING FORWARD AND NOT JUST
LOOKING AT IT- FROM-
ELECTRICITY STAVING STANDPOINT.
THANK YOU KNOW I MEAN I DO
THINK THAT THE EXTENT THAT WE
ARE SEEING A SHIFT. IN A LOT OF
WAYS YOU JUST MENTIONED WE
SHOULD BE WORKING TOGETHER AS A
LEGISLATURE. AND AN AGENCY TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
MAKE CHANGES TO ENSURE WE ARE
MOVING ENERGY EFFICIENT
VEHICLES FORWARD IN GETTING
TOWARDS THAT TARGET IS IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL. BUT I THINK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN THAT AND
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OF THIS GROUP. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- THANK YOU
PRESIDENT BETTER GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN I THINK THE FIRST
TIME THAT WE CONNECTED WAS WHEN
YOU HAD FIRST BEEN APPOINTED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND- I KNOW
THAT IT'S BEEN A VERY
INTERESTING YEAR FOR ALL OF US
RELATED TO KOBE DID EVERYTHING
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED I WANNA-
JUST ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY
THE CHAIR AND SEVERAL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES. WHO HAVE- EXPRESSED
THEIR DISAPPOINTMENT AND
FRUSTRATION WITH THE LACK TIME
AND JUST HOW LONG IT TAKES TO
GET RESPONSES OR A MOVEMENT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION I WANT TO
BRING UP THE ISSUE OTHER WAS
BROUGHT UP BEFORE AT THAT'S THE
ISSUE OF NET ENERGY METERING
AND WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THAT I
WANT TO GO AND ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THE REPORT THAT WAS. PUBLISHED
BY THE P. UC IN FEBRUARY OF
THIS YEAR UTILITY UTILITY COSTS
AND AFFORDABILITY OF THE GRID
OF THE FUTURE AND EVALUATION OF
ELECTRIC COST RATES AND EQUITY
ISSUES- ON PAGE TWENTY EIGHT
WHEN YOU GO TO WHEN THE STUDY
THAT- YOU PRODUCED- SOME
ALARMING INFORMATION. AND I'D
LIKE TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO
JUST READ A LITTLE BIT- SO THAT
WE ALL HAVE CONTACTS IN TERMS
OF WHAT I'M DESCRIBING. WHEN IT
COMES TO NET ENERGY METERING
SNAM NAM CUSTOMERS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY OLDER.
LOCATED IN HIGH INCOME AREAS
LIKELY TO OWN THEIR OWN HOME.
AND LESS LIKELY TO LIVE IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY.
CONSEQUENTLY THE COST OF NET
ENERGY METERING. ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY PAID BY
YOUNGER LESS WEALTHY AND MORE
DISADVANTAGED RATE PAYERS. MANY
OF WHOM ARE RENTERS. TO ADDRESS
THIS CONCERN- IT'S NOTED THAT
THE PC WILL BE DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT. UGH THIS YEAR
MOVING FORWARD I REPRESENT A
COMMUNITY- THAT IS 20% BELOW
THE NATIONAL POVERTY LINE. THAT
IS- IN EAST LOS ANGELES AND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE.
THAT IS NOT- SERVICE BY LADWP
BUT BY AND THEN THE- AN
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY. EDISON
IN IN THE SAME REPORT- IT
STATES THAT AS OF DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY. APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND RESIDENTIAL NAME COULD
NUMB CUSTOMERS. AND ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION CARE CUSTOMERS
PARTICIPATED- OR RECEIVE THEIR
ENERGY THROUGH EDISON. OF THESE
CARE CUSTOMERS ONLY 4%
PARTICIPATED IN THEM. MEANING
OVER ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
CARE CUSTOMERS WERE LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. OR ABOUT NINETY SIX
PERCENT. SHOULDER THE
ADDITIONAL COST BURDEN BURDEN
FROM ALL NON CUSTOMERS. THIS IS
IN YOUR REPORT. AND IT'S TAKEN
THE P. YOU SEE YEARS. YEARS AND
YEARS. TO DO SOMETHING TO
ADDRESS THE COST SHIFT. I'D
LIKE TO KNOW FROM YOU DIRECTLY.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE. TO A LOW
INCOME FAMILY THAT'S A CARE
CUSTOMER. THAT'S HAVING TO PAY
THE COST OF THE COST SHIFT AND
THE DIFFERENCE. FROM THE MORE
AFFLUENT. CUSTOMERS THAT
ACTUALLY RECEIVE THE BENEFIT
FROM THEM WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING. TO COMPARE LEADER
FOR THE RENT. PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE. AND WE AND ACTUALLY WILL
BENEFIT FROM THE PC AT
ADDRESSING. THIS BURDEN OF THE
COST SHIFT THAT HAS NOT BEEN
ADDRESSED WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
THOSE LOW INCOME FAMILIES AS TO
WHY. THE PC HAS FAILED TO ACT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD SAY
THAT I'M IS DISHEARTENED AS YOU
ARE- AND WE HAVE A AS I SPOKE
EARLIER SKEWS ME. WE HAVE A
PROCEEDING. THAT IS CURRENTLY
UNDER WAY THAT WILL- THAT IS
LOOKING VERY CLOSELY AT THE
COST SHIFT VERY CLOSELY AT THE
ISSUE THAT YOU JUST VERY WELL
DESCRIBED- I WOULD SAY THE
INEQUITY OR THE UNFAIRNESS. OF
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE- THAT THE
INTERNET ENERGY METERING- HAS
IN ITS IN ITS CURTAIN CURRENT
FORM THAT PROCEEDING WILL BE
CONCLUDING AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR AS I MENTIONED EARLIER AND
INDYCAR SHIFT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
PROCEEDING THAT WE ARE LOOKING
AT. THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE
THAT ANSWER BUT I WHAT I'M
MISSING IS THE COMPASSION. WHAT
I'M MISSING IS THE FACT THAT
IT'S- THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
FIXED YEARS AGO AND IT STILL
HASN'T. AND IT IT WEIGHS
HEAVILY ON CARE CUSTOMERS WHO
ARE ALREADY INCREDIBLY AT.
HURTING AND OUR PAVON TO PAY
THE DIFFERENCE FOR SOMEBODY WHO
IS MORE AFFLUENT WHO IS NOT
PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE INTO
THE GRID. WELL I APOLOGIZE IF I
DO NOT SEEN AND COMPASSIONATE.
AND THAT I DON'T HAVE THAT I'M
NOT SHOWING ON THE NEEDED
PASSION I THINK THAT MY
COLLEAGUES AND MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS. BUT A TEST TO.
BOTH MY PASSION AND THERE IS-
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT
ELECTRICITY IS SAFE AND
RELIABLE AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
AFFORDABLE FOR EVERYONE. AND AS
I SAID WE ARE. CURRENTLY
ADDRESSING GOING TO BE
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE I CAN'T
UNDER UNDER RULES AND
REGULATIONS TELL YOU THAT IT'S
MOST DEFINITELY THIS IS THE
DECISION OF THE PROCEEDING- I
WOULD BE GETTING OUT AHEAD OF
THE VOTES OF MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS BUT- COST SHIFT
HAS BEEN ANALYZED YOU YOU- WELL
RECITED FROM A REPORT. THERE'S
OTHER MODELING THAT WE HAVE
BEEN NOT DONE WE WILL BE TAKING
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ISSUE THIS EXTREMELY INFORMING
TO US AND WE WILL BE MAKING A
DECISION AT THE END OF THE
YEAR. AND I DO CARE DEEPLY FOR
YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND ALL AND
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
DISADVANTAGED AND IN LOW INCOME
AREAS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE WE
HAVE INCREASED THIS YEAR SADLY
BECAUSE A PANDEMIC MOSTLY
BELIEVE INCLUDE INCREASE THE
CUSTOMERS THAT- SUBSCRIBE TO
CARE. AND FARAH- AND- I'M I
THINK THAT IS A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AND I KNOW THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE STRUGGLING
STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR
ELECTRICITY BILLS. AND THIS THE
MORE EFFICIENCY THAT WE CAN
BRING TO THE ELECTRIC GRID AND
THE MORE WE CAN. DO THAT WILL
BRING- OUR RATES DOWN AND THE
MORE WE CAN DO THAT BRINGS-
GREATER EFFICIENCY IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT- GREATER
EFFECTIVENESS I SHOULD SAY. IS
BETTER FOR EVERYONE
PARTICULARLY THOSE FOLKS THAT
DO LIVE IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND- ARE ON MORE
SUBJECT TO SOME OF THE
POLLUTANTS AND SOME OF THE
OTHER- DIFFICULTIES THAT COME
FROM ON INDUSTRIAL WASTE IF YOU
WILL. I WANT TO JUST- A
CLARIFYING QUESTION BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION BEING SHARED. ON
SOCIAL MEDIA WITH RELATES
RELATING TO A PARTICULAR BILL
OTHER WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY HOUSE
AND WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY IT IS
REGARDING RATES CAN YOU PLEASE
CLARIFY ON THE RECORD WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY RATES. IS THAT THE
UTILITIES THEMSELVES OR IS IT
THE TO UC. THIS ABUSING SO WHEN
WE SEE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
REYES REPAIR- REYES RAISE THE
RED THE RATES ON ON UTILITIES
THAT'S BECAUSE THE PC HAS NOT
ACT ACTED IS THAT ACCURATE.
RELATED TO NINETY EIGHT RELATED
TO MAKE SHIFTING COSTS. I'M
SORRY- IF I MAY JUST GREAT TOO
LITTLE BED- THE RATE RATES-
THAT ARE INCREASED BY THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES HAVE
TO BE APPROVED BY THE FUSEE.
CORRECT SO THAT MEANS THAT THE
P. U. C. IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
EITHER ACTING OR NOT ACTING ON
THE COST SHIFT. WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE YES SO JUST FOR THE
RECORD THE PC IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE CAUTIOUS AND NOT THE
INDIVIDUAL INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES CORRECT. AS IT COMES
AS IT THREE AS AS YOU'RE
REFERRING TO- NET ENERGY
METERING YES. I THINK THAT
WOULD BE ACCURATE NO WAY YOU
LAID IT OUT. IS THAT IN MY IN
MY CORRECT. ADDRESS YES THANK
YOU. OKAY I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT ON
RECORD BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION AS TO WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE COST SHIFT
WHETHER IT'S THE UTILITIES THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
THEMSELVES OR WHETHER IT'S THE
P. YOU SEE IN BECAUSE WE HAVE
SEEN. A FAILURE TO ACT FOR THE
ON THE NET ENERGY METERING IN
THE COSTA FOR MANY YEARS NOW
THERE SEEMS TO BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO GET TO A
BETTER PLACE BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR WHICH IS WHAT I HEARD YOU
SAY EARLIER- AND I'M REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT BECAUSE
AGAIN I DON'T BELIEVE THAT. MY
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS IN EAST
LOS ANGELES WHO ARE ALREADY 20%
BELOW THE NATIONAL POVERTY
LINE. SHOULD HAVE TO. CARRY THE
BURDEN OF HAVING TO PAY THE
DIFFERENCE. FOR A MORE AFFLUENT
COMMUNITY RIGHT NEXT DOOR. YES
THANK YOU. OKAY I WANT ONE JUST
FINAL QUESTION A NIGHT I
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
CONSIDERATION BUT IS IT THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO PUSH LEGISLATION
TO MAKE THE P. YOU SEE OCT OR
SHOULD THE P. YOU SEE ACT BE
DOING ITS JOB AND- MOVING
FORWARD WITH WHAT'S NEEDED.
WELL I'M THE LEGISLATURE IS A
SEPARATE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
AND I BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE
EVERY RIGHT AND RESPONSIBILITY
TO PASS LAWS THAT INSTRUCT THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH. HOW TO DO
THEIR JOB SO I WOULD NEVER
QUESTION THE AUTHORITY OR THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE HOWEVER HAVING SAID
THAT. WE OF THE PC OR ANY OTHER
STATE AGENCY THAT I HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO OPERATE IN A
VERY EFFECTIVE- MANNER AND TO
TAKE CARE OF THOSE THEY ARE.
RESPONSIBLE FOR AND THAT'S IN
OUR CASE IT'S THE RATEPAYERS
AND THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA SO
WE SHOULD ALWAYS ACT ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU- PRESIDENT DODGER REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER BECAUSE-
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
LEGISLATION THAT WE WERE
MOVING- MOST RECENTLY HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY IS ACTUALLY
LEGISLATION THAT WAS NEEDED HAD
THE PC ACTED ACCORDINGLY IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS NOW I RECOGNIZE.
THAT UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP
THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE AND I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING THAT UP BUT IT REALLY
DOES BEG THE QUESTION THAT IF
THERE IS RESPECT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE PC HAS NOT
ACTED ON THE LEGISLATION PASSED
TO ENSURE. THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING THE COST SHIFT
RELATED TO THE NET ENERGY
METERING THEN WE'RE GOING
AROUND IN CIRCLES IN TERMS OF
PASSING LEGISLATION THAT'S
IMPORTANT YEARS AND YEARS WHERE
THERE IS NO ACTION. AND NOW
HERE WE ARE WITH YOUR OWN
REPORT THAT CAME OUT IN
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR
INDICATING A REAL INEQUITY
ISSUE RELATED TO SOLAR AND
RELATED TO NET ENERGY METERING
AND RELATED TO UTILITIES
OVERALL SO AGAIN I KNOW THAT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
WORKING ON AND HOPEFULLY BY THE
END OF THIS YEAR WE HAVE A
RESOLUTION BUT JUST KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SEVERAL OF US THAT
ARE LOOKING AT CLIMATE CHANGE
AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE GRID- THE
REALITY OF. A REACHING 1100%
RENEWABLES BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
AND OTHER GOALS THAT WE HAVE
PUT UPON THE STATE THAT I
BELIEVE IN. BUT BY DOING SO WE
ALSO NEED THE P. YOU SEE TO ACT
AND TO ALSO FIGURE OUT A WAY
THAT WE DON'T PUT THE BURDENS
ON LOW INCOME FAMILY SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T OWN THE ROOF
OVER THEIR HEADS. RENTERS ALSO
NEED AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART
OF THE CLIMATE SOLUTION- AND IT
SHOULDN'T BE ON THE BURKE ON
THE BACKS OF LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. YOU HEAR ME
LOUD AND CLEAR BECAUSE THIS IS
AN ISSUE ABOUT EQUITY. AND
ENSURING THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WE ARE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. VERSES THIS
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE HAVING
NOW AND THEN WE'VE BEEN HAVING
SINCE I MET YOU IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. I HEAR YOU VERY LOUD
AND CLEAR. AND I RESPECT YOU.
AS DO MY FELLOW COMMISSIONERS
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
VERY HELPFUL. AND CONSTRUCTIVE
CRITICISM. THANK YOU I'M GOOD
MISTER CHAIR. DR KIRK- WELL
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH I THINK
THE PRESIDENT OF- THE P. YOU
SEE HAS ONE OF THE MOST
THANKLESS JOBS IN THE- IN THE
STATE. I KNOW IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT JOB AND I'LL BE
ASKING YOU QUESTIONS TO AND- I
THINK YOUR RESPONSE TODAY TO
OUR QUESTIONS HAS BEEN QUITE
RESPONSIVE AND I APPRECIATED.
AND I APPRECIATE THE DIFFICULTY
OF THE JOB THAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
ONE OF THE MAIN SEE ONE OF THE
MAIN CONCERNS I'VE HAD AS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE AND I
HAVE BEEN ASKING THIS FOR A
LONG TIME. IS WHY ARE WE MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN OTHER STATES. WE
TEND TO GET FAIRLY VAGUE
ANSWERS. ARM I'M GOING TO BE
SENDING YOU A LETTER- WHICH
WILL DESCRIBE. A WAY TO MAKE
THIS LESS- LAST DAY IN
PARTICULAR THERE'S A BILL THEIR
KEYS ME THERE'S A- LET EXCUSE
ME A PAPER THAT'S WRITTEN. BY
THE HARSH SHE'S ME HAAS ENERGY
INSTITUTE AT UC BERKELEY- BY
BARGE DEAN VALLEY AND SOLLY-
WHICH COULD HAS A METHODOLOGY
OF. TAKING THE FIXED COSTS.
TAKING THE VARIABLE COSTS
SEPARATING THOSE OUT SEPARATELY
IN A NUMBER OF CATEGORIES IN
PARTICULAR LOOKING AT. OUR
GENERATION SO THERE'S SOME
FIXED COSTS ARE LIKE THE ABOVE
MARKET RATES THAT WE PAY TO
INITIALLY GET SOLAR STARTED-
THEN THERE'S THE COST OF
ACTUALLY GENERATING THE ENERGY.
THERE'S FIXED COSTS FOR
TRANSMISSION AS WELL AS
VARIABLE COSTS. MOSTLY FIXED
COST FOR DISTRIBUTION BUT SOME
VARIABLE COST. SOME COST DUE TO
POLLUTION WHICH IS SOCIAL COST
AND THEN SOMETHING WHICH IS
ACTUALLY LARGER THAN
TRANSMISSION. WHICH IS
SOMETHING YOU'VE JUST BEEN
ASKED ABOUT WHICH IS THE
SUBSIDY FOR ROOFTOP SOLAR IT'S
ACTUALLY LARGER THAN LEAST ON
THIS GRAPH IF I LOOK AT IT IT
LOOKS TO BE LARGER THAN THE
COST OF TRANSMISSION. BOB AT
ANY RATE IF YOU COULD AND AGAIN
I'LL PUT THIS IN A LETTER. IF
YOU COULD- TELL US HOW THESE
VARIOUS COST COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES. SO WE CAN SEE OF THE
NEARLY DOUBLE THE NATIONAL
RATE. HOW MUCH OF THAT IS DUE
TO OUR COST OF DISTRIBUTION AND
GENERATION. HOW MUCH OF IT IS
DUE TO- ENERGY PROGRAMS LIKE-
ENERGY CONSERVATION WHICH
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT. AS WELL AS-
ROOFTOP SOLAR. SO IF YOU THAT'S
THE GENERAL IDEA AGAIN I WILL
SEND YOU A LETTER ALONG WITH
THE REFERENCE TO THIS PAPER AND
IF YOU COULD JUST COMPARE
AVERAGE US COSTS FOR THESE
VARIOUS- PARTS OF THE- PUZZLE
HERE WE CAN GET A BETTER IDEA
OF WIRE COSTS ARE SO HIGH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION AND I'M
ON TEN MILLION WITH THE PAPER I
DON'T HAVE IT IN FRONT OF ME-
DR BORENSTEIN HAS INDEED
TESTIFIED IN ONE OF OUR- PUBLIC
HEARINGS. ON THE PAPER AND ON
SOME OF THE THEORY THAT THAT HE
HAS PUT FORTH- ONE OF THE A
COUPLE OF COSTS WHEN YOU DID
MENTION OF AND ONE THAT THERE
IS ANOTHER DRIVER OF THE
UTILITY COSTS AND RATE DRIVERS.
ONE IS OF COURSE- YOU YOU
SPOKE- ABOUT THE DISTRIBUTION
COSTS TRANSMISSION COSTS- ARE
REALLY ESCALATING QUITE HEAVILY-
AND ALSO OUR WELFARE MITIGATION
COSTS. YES BOTH THE- BOTH THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT COSTS AND
THEN OF COURSE THE HARDENING.
OF THE SYSTEMS IN OUR IOUS IT'S
COSTLY AND- THOSE ARE TWO.
PRETTY STRONG RIGHT DRIVERS
RIGHT NOW I'M GONNA ASK- AND I
DON'T KNOW ALL OF THE DETAILS
OF OTHER STATES I DON'T KNOW
THAT MISTER RANDOLPH WELL
EITHER THE COMPARISONS BUT HE
MIGHT HAVE A BETTER IDEA THAN I
DO A MORE THOROUGH IDEA YEAH
LET ME JUST TAKE THAT OUR RATES
WERE ALREADY TWICE AS HIGH
BEFORE WE WERE PUTTING ALL THIS
MONEY INTO WILDFIRE. BUT ANYWAY
GO AHEAD MISTER RANDALL. YEAH
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK-
IN MINUTES ACTUALLYAND-
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS- ANALYTICAL
SUGGESTION- YEAH I'LL NOTE THAT
WE ALREADY DO- PROVIDED ANNUAL
SUMMARY OF EACH OF THE
CATEGORIES IT YEAH- YOU HAVE
OUTLINED. YOU KNOW WITHIN
CALIFORNIA'S A STARTING POINT
IN THE AND I'M SURE YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH IT WHAT WE
DETERMINES THE AB SIXTY SEVEN
REPORT- WHICH DOES DETAIL- YOU
KNOW BOTH THE- AMOUNT ON EACH
YEAR- EACH OF THOSE CATEGORIES
YOU'VE OUTLINED- PLUS NOW THAT
THE AB SIXTY SEVEN REPORT HAS
BEEN LAID OUT IN THAT DETAIL-
FOR. CLOSE TO FIFTEEN YEARS NOW
YOU CAN ALSO SEE THOSE LONG
TERM TRENDS IN THOSE DETAILS-
IT IT IS A GOOD QUESTION TO
LOOK AT NEAR THE NATIONAL
TRENDS IN EACH ONE- AND WE'D BE
HAPPY TO LOOK INTO THAT. YOU
KNOW JUST CAUTION- WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE DATA IS IN EACH
STATE AND YOU KNOW WE WOULD
TYPICALLY FOR THAT ANALYSIS
TURN TO- THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT
OF ENERGY- TO MAKE THOSE
COMPARISONS WHICH WE CAN TRY-
YOU KNOW HER ADDITIONALLY- NOT
TO PUT IT BACK IN THE HOSPITAL
BUSINESS- YOU KNOW WE WOULD
ALSO PROBABLY REACH OUT TO MR
BORENSTEIN AND OTHERS- TO WORK
WITH THEM ON THAT SAME ANALYSIS.
HI WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU AND
ANYTHING YOU KNOW I'LL BE GLAD
TO TALK WITH PEOPLE'S LIVES. IN
THE ACADEMIC WORLD IF YOU WANT
TO GET SOME HELP FROM THEM I'D
BE GLAD TO TALK TO THEM AS WELL.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
LETTER AND OF COURSE RESEARCH
INTO RESPONDING. IN A TIMELY
MANNER I MIGHT ADD. ALL RIGHT-
SO WE HAVE DISCUSSED- SO
SOMETHING THAT CAME UP WHEN THE
ISO WAS HERE FOR AND YOU WERE
HERE AS WELL FOR AN EARLIER
DISCUSSION AS WELL AS THE
ENERGY COMMISSION. THERE WAS A
BIT TOO MUCH GOING ON FOR MY TO
DIG INTO IT TOO MUCH- BUT I'VE
TALKED WITH COMMISSIONER-
CLIFF. RIGHT RACETRACK SHAMAN
WRECK SHAMAN SHAMAN RUSSIA
OFTEN. OF AND HE IS- CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT WE DO DURING THE
WINTER ARE WHEN WE'VE GONE OVER
TO WHAT WILL PROBABLY BE
LARGELY SOLAR AND WIND SOME
GEOTHERMAL- THE PROBLEM IS WIND
AND SOLAR. ARE NOT
COMPLEMENTARY DURING THE WINTER
OFFSHORE WIND GOES DOWN WITH
SOLAR GOES DOWN IN THE WINTER-
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT LAND WIND
BUT THAT'S NOT TERRIBLY
RELIABLE HERE IN THE STATE- AND
WE CAN GET SOME SORT OF BALANCE
PARTICULARLY WERE WILLING TO
IMPORT SAY WYOMING WIND- IF
THEY HAVE MORE DURING THE
WINTER. THEN THEY CAN USE-
ALSO- IMPORTING HYDRO FROM THE
PACIFIC BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
JUST LOOK AT THIS IN IN MORE
DETAIL. I HAVE SEEN. OUR
ESTIMATES OF THE IMBALANCE BY
JACK BRAUER OF UC- IRVINE- WHO
SHOWS A LARGE. COMMISSIONER
CLIFF IS LOOKING INTO THIS- BUT
I'M JUST ASKING THAT YOU TAKE A
VERY HARD LOOK AT THIS SO WE'RE
NOT PLAYING CATCH UP IN. TWENTY
THIRTY BECAUSE FRANKLY IT TAKES.
DECADES TO GET NEW SOURCES
ONLINE- PUMPED STORAGE IS NOT
GOING TO BE ADEQUATE OVER THIS
TIME SCALE BECAUSE IT'S JUST
TOO LARGE AN AMOUNT YOU DON'T
HAVE THAT MUCH WATER- IT'S GOOD
FOR TWENTY FOUR HOURS PERHAPS
FORTY EIGHT HOURS PERHAPS. EVEN
A COUPLE OF DAYS BUT THAT'S NOT
A GOOD FOR ALL SCHOOLS AND- SO
IT REALLY MEANS BRINGING UP.
WHOLE NEW METHODS- JACK BRAUER
WHO I MENTIONED- LIKES HYDROGEN
STORAGE. THERE CAN BE MANY
OTHERS BUT THE ANSWER I'VE
GOTTEN AGAIN IN THE PAST HAVE
BEEN FAIRLY- VAGUE. AND I JUST
LIKE- YOU TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
YOU CONSIDER THIS QUESTION IS
AND WHAT MIGHT YOU DO TO LOOK
INTO IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR A RECORD OF YES QUICK
RECORD SHOP AND- IT IS- THE
COMMISSIONER WHO CURRENTLY HAS
THE PRECEDING THE- THE I. R. P.
DECISION- THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER AND AS I ALSO MENTIONED
EARLIER WE WILL BE VOTING ON
THAT- DECISION AT THE END OF
THE MONTH. AND IN THAT DECISION
IN THE PROPOSED TO SKIP
DECISION SKEWS ME- THERE ARE
SEVERAL ELIGIBLE RESOURCES-
THAT ARE ARE BEING CALLED UPON
AND CALLED OUT BY- BY THE
DECISION AND PROPOSED DECISION
AND THAT INCLUDES THE GREEN
HYDROGEN. AND THERE WILL BE A
FINER DEFINITIONS I BELIEVE
AND- PUMP STORAGE OR LONG TERM
STORAGE SKEWS ME AND- THE OTHER
RESOURCES THAT- YOU MENTIONED.
SO I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IT
WE AS A COMMISSION ARE THE
COMMISSIONERS MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT ANY IMBALANCE AND- WE- WE
ALSO AS YOU MENTIONED- WE DO.
CAN AND DO IMPORT WIND- AT WHEN
THAT IS AVAILABLE DURING DURING
THE WINTER SO- ALL OF THESE
RESOURCES I'M EXCITED ABOUT NEW
TECHNOLOGY I'M EXCITED ABOUT
BRINGING THE MON OPENING THAT
DOOR VERY EXCITED THAT WE HAVE
A- COMPANION IN DOING THIS AND
NOW WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- IN NEED BY NEED
MINISTRATION. SO IN TERMS OF
OFFSHORE WIND THAT'S-
THANKFULLY WE THE GOVERNOR HAS
WORKED HARD TO- WORKED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. OF DEFENSE AND WE
NOW WILL HAVE SOME- I'M SURE
LEASES THAT CAN BE. CALLED UPON
IN IN OUR HARD WORK IN THE
YEARS AHEAD I LIKE YOU HOPE
THAT ALL OF THESE RESOURCES
THAT WE'VE BEEN WE MENTIONED
AND WILL BE ARE MENTIONED IN
THE PROPOSED DECISION WILL BE
MENTIONED IN OTHER PROCEEDINGS
BEFORE THE P. YOU SEE. ARE WELL
UNDER WAY- AND WE'RE CALLING
FOR MANY OF THEM TO BE WELL
UNDERWAY BEFORE WELL BEFORE
TWENTY THIRTY. AND WE'RE DOING
THAT IN SEVERAL PROCEEDINGS BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY AND WHAT'S IN
FRONT OF US RIGHT NOW. IS THE-
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
DECISION. YES OF THAT DECISION
IS GOING TO PRIMARILY DEAL WITH
LONG TERM MEANING MORE THAN
ABOUT FOUR HOURS- DEALING WITH
SORT OF THE DAY TIME SCALE AS
OPPOSED TO SEASONAL TIME SCALES.
AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE IT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL TO HAVE
BACKGROUND WORK SIMPLY TO
SKETCH OUT HOW BIG THE PROBLEM
IS AGAIN OFFSHORE WIND GOES
DOWN IN THE WINTER NOT UP ALL
RIGHT AND THE- THE QUESTION
THEN IS HOW SORT OF BACK OF THE
ENVELOPE ALMOST BUT HOW BIG IS
THE PROBLEM AND SORT OF WHAT
TECHNOLOGIES. ARM ARE OUT THERE
TO SOLVE IT AND- BASICALLY I'D
LIKE TO SAY. IN THE NEXT YEAR
OR TWO TO TAKE A LOOK AT
PROPOSING SOME OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THE LEGISLATURE HAS OF COURSE
THE EXPERTISE TO SAY. YOU KNOW
YOU SHOULD DO THIS WITH
HYDROGEN STORAGE WE SHOULD DO
IT WITH FLOW BATTERIES OR-
IMPORTING WIT WIND AND- HYDRO
FROM OTHER PLACES WE DON'T HAVE
THAT THAT WE DEPEND UPON YOU.
SO I'M JUST ASKING THAT- FOR
SUPPORT OF FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN.
GETTING SORT OF A SKELETAL
OUTLINE OF WHERE WE MIGHT GO-
SAID THAT- YOU CAN INFORM US
AND OTHER DECISION MAKERS IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AS TO YOU
KNOW WHAT WE THINK THE NEED
MIGHT BE. AGAIN WE GET
ENTHUSIASTS LIKE JACK BRAUER
FROM UC- IRVINE AND HE HAS HIS
VIEWPOINT ON HOW IT SHOULD BE
DONE- BUT I'D REALLY LIKE TO
SEE THE EXPERTISE OF THE P. YOU
SEE- LOOKING AT THIS BECAUSE
FRANKLY HE'S- THERE MAY BE
OTHER ESTIMATES OUT THERE BUT I
HAVEN'T SEEN A LOT OF THEM. I
WILL ENTHUSIASTICALLY. LOOK AT
IT- ACT INFORMING ON YOU AND
YOUR FELLOW AND- MEMBERS IN IN
LOOKING AT THE IMBALANCE WE
WILL BE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
THIS WITH A MORE THOROUGH
ANALYSIS. AND I'M AND WE WILL
BUILD OFF OF THE DISCUSSIONS
YOU HAVE HAD WITH COMMISSIONER
REX SHAMAN. OKAY WELL AGAIN I
WAS VERY IMPRESSED WITH THE
COMMISSIONERS- RESPONSIVENESS
AND JUST WANT TO ASK FOR YOUR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT- AND- THAT
THOSE ARE MY QUESTIONS IT'S
BEEN VERY PLEASANT TALKING TO
YOU ALL AGAIN. AGAIN I KNOW
YOU'VE GOT A VERY DIFFICULT JOB
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING WILLING
TO DO IT. I'LL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IT IS CHALLENGING- IT'S
VERY CHALLENGING BUT THERE'S A
TERRIFIC STAFF HERE AT THE C.
P. YOU SEE. THAT I HEAVILY
DEPEND ON AND I AM VERY LUCKY
TO HAVE SOME VERY SMART WISE
AND- AND COMMITTED- FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I JUST WANTED TO ASK ONE
QUESTION I DON'T THINK THAT WE
HAVE ANY OTHER MEMBERS WERE
SEEKING TO BE RECOGNIZED BUT
ALL THIS WOULD BE MY LAST
QUESTION THEN WILL TURN OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND THIS IS
ACTUALLY FOR YOU PRESS ABOUT
HER AND ALSO FOR. OUR ACTING
DIRECTOR YEP KAMALA. I HOPE
SHE'S STILL HERE WITH THIS- BUT
THIS IS REGARDING THE RECENT.
WE RECENTLY HEARD IN THE NEWS
ABOUT. THE CCA IN RIVERSIDE
FILING FOR BANKRUPTCY- EARLIER
THIS MONTH THIS RAISES CONCERNS
ABOUT THE STABILITY. OF OUR
ELECTRIC SECTOR AND SHOULD WE
BE WORRIED MORE BANKRUPTCIES
ARE IN THE FUTURE. HOW HAVE
YOUR AGENCIES INCREASE
MONITORING OF THE STABILITY OF
OUR ENERGY INSTITUTIONS TO
ENSURE. BANKRUPTCIES WAS AN
ISOLATED THIS PARTICULAR
BANKRUPTCY WAS AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT. AND WHAT DOES THIS
BANKRUPTCY MEAN FOR THE CCA
CUSTOMERS AND THE CUSTOMERS OF
EDISON. HOW WILL THEY BE
PROTECTED. I WILL I THINK SPEAK
FIRST IF THAT'S OKAY WITH AMY-
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN THAT YOU'RE SPEAKING
OF THE WESTERN CLEAN ENERGY
DESERTIFICATION IN BANKRUPTCY
AND WE DO- KEEP CLOSE. TABS IF
YOU WILL ON THE HEALTH OF THE
CCA'S WE DO NOT FULLY REGULATE
THE CCA'S AS I KNOW YOU'RE
FULLY AWARE- WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
ADDISON- BECAUSE THAT THE
CUSTOMERS AT WCVE WILL BE
RETURNED TO- TO ADDISON. AND-
SO- THAT ACTUALLY WE'VE
ALREADY- TAKE AN ACTION- ON ON
ON THAT TO SOME DEGREE BUT AND
YET IS BEEN ADMIN OFFICE BEEN
DEEP IN VAULT OUR MOST ON A
DAILY BASIS IN TRACKING- THE
DECERTIFICATION BANKRUPTCY SO I
WANT TO ADD TO GIVE AS MANY
DETAILS AS HE HAS- THANK YOU
PRESIDENT THAT'S WE ALL JUST
REAL QUICKLY WALK THROUGH- THE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE THERE WITH
THAT PARTICULAR EVENT- SO-
WESTERN CLEAN ENERGY'S
CUSTOMERS ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING RETURNED TO. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON BUNDLED
SERVICE NOW SO THEY'LL BE BUT-
DISTRIBUTION AND GENERATION
CUSTOMERS- IN IN COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE LAW THAT REQUIRES
ANY RETURN OF CUSTOMERS ARE NOT
RESOLVED AND- EIGHT IN. ARE
RATE IMPACTS FOR THE- EXISTING
CUSTOMERS THERE'S A PROCESS
WHERE ALTERNATELY THE RETURNING
CUSTOMERS WILL PAY- A SURCHARGE
THAT COVERS- THE COST OF THE
INCREMENTAL COST OF SERVING
THEM FOR THE FIRST SIX MONTHS-
SOME OF THAT INCREMENTAL COSTS
DOES GET COVERED BY- A LETTER
OF CREDIT EACH W. R. EACH CCA
IS REQUIRED TO HAVE-
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE LETTERS OF
CREDIT ARE RELATIVELY SMALL
COMPARED TO THE COST OF
RETURNING CUSTOMERS OR SOME OF
THAT. WILL BE BORNE BY THE
RETURNING CUSTOMERS BASED ON
CURRENT ESTIMATES AND THIS
COULD CHANGE- SINCE SOME OF
THIS IS BASED ON FORWARD ENERGY
PRICES- AND THOSE WILL OFTEN
THERE'S A RAPIDLY CHANGING
RIGHT NOW- ABOUT 40% OF W. C.
ECONOMY IS ACTUALLY WILL SEE A
SLIGHT RATE DECREASE. WHEN THEY
RETURN TO ADDISON SERVICE ON
THOSE ARE THE- CARE AND FAIR
CUSTOMERS TO LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS- AND THEN THE
REMAINING 60% THE NON LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS WILL LIKELY
SEE BETWEEN A POINT EIGHT CENT
AND A PENNY INCREASE ARM AND
RATES THAT AVERAGES OUT TO
ABOUT TEN DOLLARS. A MONTH SO
NOT INSIGNIFICANT- RATE CHANGE
FOR ABOUT 60% OF THE CUSTOMERS-
YEAH I DO WANT TO BUILD ON
SOMETHING PRESENT BACHELOR SAID
ON IN TERMS OF MONITORING THE
HEALTH OF THE ENTITIES- WE DO
VERY CLOSELY MONITOR HEALTH OF
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES-
AND HAVE- QUARTERLY MEETINGS
WITH THEM- WORKING THROUGH-
THEIR- THEIR FINANCES THEIR
RATINGS- THERE TO MONITOR THEIR
HEALTH AND I HAVE- SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS IN CASE WE NEED TO
GET INVOLVED IN SOMETHING-
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE SAME
REGULATORY JURISDICTION OVER
THE CCA'S- WE DON'T HAVE
SIMILAR MEETINGS WITH THEM- IN
THIS PARTICULAR INSTANCE- ONE
STUDY SEE. I DECLARED FOR
BANKRUPTCY WE DID START HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH CAL CCA- TO
GET INFORMATION THROUGH THEM
ON- WHAT THE STATE OF FINANCE
THIS. FOR C. INTO- WE HAVE THE
DIRECT INFORMATION BUT WE DID
GET INFORMATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT- OR TO TRY TO HAVE SOME
ASSURANCES THAT THERE'S NOT
GONNA BE A CHAIN REACTION-
AMONG OTHER CCA'S- OVER THE
SUMMER BASED ON PEOPLE GETTING
NERVOUS ABOUT THE OVERALL
FINANCIAL MODEL WE DON'T. THANK
THAT'S A RISK BASED ON WHAT WE
KNOW SO FAR- AND WE DO THINK
THAT THE SITUATION WOULD W. C.
E. R. IS FAIRLY UNIQUE. ARE
GIVEN- THEY'RE BASICALLY
STARTED SERVING CUSTOMERS AT
THE VERY BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC- THAT THEY HAVE A- A
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH NUMBER
OF LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS. AND
ADD TO PERSONALLY HIGH NUMBER
OF FOLKS WHO WERE UNABLE TO PAY
THEIR ELECTRIC BILLS DURING THE
UP ENERGY KERR DURING THE
PANDEMIC. NO I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I THINK CLEARLY WE'RE GOING
TO. NO SEE THIS HOPEFULLY JUST
AS A RARE OCCURRENCE A RARE
EVENT AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
STABILITY OF CCA'S IS SORT OF.
FUNDAMENTAL AND THE THEIR
DECISION MAKING IS. POSITIONING
THEM FOR SUCCESS DOWN THE ROAD
BUT I L. COULD ALSO. SIGNAL
THAT THERE'S SOME DEFICIENCY
AND HOW OF THE FUNDAMENTALS OF
THE OF THE FINANCES ARE
STRUCTURED AND HOW THE LONG
TERM VIABILITY COULD BE
JEOPARDIZED IF. THERE SOMETHING
MORE SYSTEMIC AT PLAY AND SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US. TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS
WE'RE GOING TO OBVIOUSLY HAVE.
OUR CONVERSATIONS HEALTHY
CONVERSATIONS WITH- CCA'S AND
UNDERSTAND- THEIR THOUGHTS AND-
BUT BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT DID HAPPEN ON THE SERVER
SIDE UP COMING. AND WE THINK WE
NEED TO- PAY ATTENTION SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR INSIGHT ON
THAT AND CERTAINLY AN
ADDITIONAL. BUT YOU CAN GIVE US
AND WE'LL BE WORKING WITH THE
I. O. U.'S AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM AS WELL.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO-
PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT THIS
IS A PART OF THE HEARING WILL
TURN TO. THE PUBLIC THERE'S NO
ONE HERE IN THE GALLERY AND OR
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER- TO
BE RECOGNIZED AND SO WE WILL
TURN TO OUR- VIDEO. VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE. AND
WILL ASK OUR MODERATOR TO CHECK
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO IS
PREPARED TO. ADDRESS THIS-
HEARING- FOR PUBLIC COMMENT WE
ARE ASKED THAT THE TESTIMONY OR
ANY COMMENTS BE LIMITED TO ONE
MINUTE. SO MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD. PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING. TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL WILL BEGIN.
OF COURSE SPACE THEM IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE PHONE. USING A SPEAKER
PHONE PLEASE PICK UP THE
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING ANY OF
THE NUMBERS.
AND THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO ONE QUEUING UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY WITH THANK
YOU- AND WE APPRECIATE AGAIN
PRESIDENT BOETTCHER YOU AND
YOUR TEAM- BEING HERE I KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE A LOT GOING ON I
KNOW THAT THIS WAS A CHALLENGE
TO TRY TO. NAVIGATE TIME FOR
YOU TO BE HERE BUT I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR EFFORTS
AND I AND AS I SAID BEFORE
CERTAINLY- I WILL SEE YOU AS
PER SHOOTING IN ALONG WITH SOME
OF THE KEY PEOPLE THERE TO TRY
TO. WRESTLE THE FUTURE OF THE
CPC AND TRY TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE- STRUCTURAL ISSUES AND-
ACCOUNTABILITY ISSUE SO I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING OUR
COMMENTS TODAY IN THE SPIRIT OF
WHICH THEY WERE GIVEN. AND
THAT'S A CONSTRUCTIVE-
DIRECTION AND FOX. AND
CERTAINLY ARE ACTING DIRECTOR
OF MISCHIEF. A KICKER GOLLA- WE
WELCOME YOU AND APPRECIATE
YOUR- OFFER TO SUFFICIENT WORK
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE DOING.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
BOTH OF YOU AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
THIS HAS CONCLUDED OUR AGENDA
FOR TODAY AND I SEE NO OTHER.
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
SEEKING RECOGNITION. THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.